we'll finally recalibrate the camera for someone please mm-hmm okay I'll
then I'll recalibrate I'm so sorry I'm sorry reflynn don't cry I don't cry my
little reflings I'm here and I'm about to buzz oh my god hello hello I said I'm
disconnected you guys hear that I just got disconnected am I here sorry I was
getting the tea a vtuber blocked me on Twitter I'm so sorry how did you get it
to capture it's really close to the revamped or something hello I sorry I
took so long I was just discovered I was blocked by a vtuber on Twitter because
I posted my income laughing because I just showed mercy at mercies like wait I know her
that's a streamer I'm like oh right anyway so I've just got the tea but it's fine the
tea's fine what the heck can I see it right I'll DM you at Denver but apparently it's a streamer I
didn't recognize them and then mersey's like what the fuck I know her like oh well she hates me
because wait wait I'll quote it well I quote it I mean it's not I just find it funny that
they insulted me and then popped off I have no idea because it blocked me but there you go Denver
there's the tea don't clock it too hard how pet literally it's it oh fuck I'll just read the
comment because it's funny one hour ago that's because you're a part of a lude smaller agency
in quotation marks well yeah I start from the ground up you think this is hollow life
which honestly has to be the easiest job with pay pigs and I'm like
that is so fucking rude to the viewer that is so fucking rude to the viewer I am so sorry
but those attitudes and nastiness is why if you do not show your appreciation
in the basic way in any way you can so last night for example I recorded two collab ASMRs and then
more SFX and all that shit I've had seven hours of sleep because I'm also juggling everything for
my daughters um I'm streaming every day and like I'm trying to show appreciation for the people
that do enjoy me and watch me and someone's analysis was it must be so fun having pay pigs
no motherfucker ew don't be so fucking gross honestly a damn no fandom here rip rip but anyway
I'm a good pay piggy though no don't encourage her don't encourage her she's gonna hate me
well she blocked me so she didn't give a shit about me I can't believe it
streamer doesn't like me what am I gonna do oh well I guess ASMR collab with her is off the cards
hold on let me take my clothes off it's a bit a bit hot in here damn
uh bruh they say that to every feature bro since they all get donations I don't know why
find I'm cringe I'll do it one last thing to edit oh that's another thing oh I also fell into
like three collabs yesterday I like stumbled my way into three collabs uh I I don't know how I do it
so miss ma from being your birthday's coming off and I'm like ah let me in on that eh eh
um she was very keen to invite me into a discord but the discord's full of other streamers I
haven't been able to get my little tentacles into and then I kind of accidentally stumbled into two more
because we were on the topic sorry this is just straight up yapping forget the game okay this is
just how you talk to other vtubers so they were all one of them was like are you all corporate
vtubers so then I like you know threw in my joke I was like I was like oh I'm aid of agency
just so I can have pals like as a little joke type thing and she was like I'm gonna do that and I was
like oh well the the starting fee was 60 000 us dollars and she was like I'm absolutely not gonna
do it I'm just like yeah I don't recommend it it's pretty rough um yeah it takes a year development
all that so you need time okay um and then she's just like oh I wish I could no no don't don't
don't sorry and thank you for the tip his message was oink oink if you heard uh
don't start oinking out in here we we don't do that here okay you make 20 percent of your
starting fee what can I say uh she was hard oh no sorry I don't work hard for the money apparently
I've got pay to do who said you can't buy friends real I only cost 60 no no no don't start and the
I go thank you for the extended membership don't you start don't you no no piggy I'm always don't
you start you goofy givers I'm not a pay pig I'm more like a pay boy what we're getting so specific
Sean is gonna become a vtuber master broly legend no so this is the line for the pity no
you work like way harder than a lot of vtubers you're barely even sleep
literally I've had seven hours I was up recording um recording the pregnancy one tomorrow have some
bacon and on stop it oh shit I just spilled tea down me oh no god what is it with me and spilling
liquids recently and yes yes yes ink refling I know it's a really easy joke yes I want to
say but I'm going to refrain like a good little little strummer what's going on the day it's just
no hot man it's just no hot man okay I'm sorry she's incandescent um a hug for a hag stop stop
that is one that's hilarious out no a sleepy phoenix I'm more of a bark bark kind of guy you
stop that behavior young man stop it refluence you're winding me up right let me finish my tea
hmm are you squiddin me right now exactly we aren't pigs at least let me we can call over the
place not toink need to get it right no let me how often do you shower I stopped now that my dad's
gone no I did have one last night because uh um I got a new lush package oh my god what's that
the streamer actually treating themselves hi thank you kaiton for the um the tip and no I did shower
yesterday but I don't really need to do it daily anymore now that my dad's gone xD so I'm not really
planning on no oink just ink real rott maxon ink not oink no just stop why are we getting asked at
never ask a vtuber stop I want to make that meme hold on let me write that down write that down
sorry I spam everything into this random chat it's the most nonsense I literally have a picture
of fucking misma of june off from idol n and then emmy had together in my notes all together
wait what was the note I've already forgotten never ask a vtuber how often they shower okay
so it's like never ask a man of salary never ask a woman her age and never ask a vtuber how often
um okay
to be honest got a point if you are at home and not getting sweaty and gross I mean
mommy's stinky feet in real life you want to smell my feet cheese sorry that's absolutely disgusting
that's actually minion don't ever say that sentence again do you understand me young lady yes I'm sorry
that is horrific there's a multiplayer mode in this I could never figure it out aren't the servers like
was that in a park
am I being enough oh no I'm not right okay
now athlete just oh I did not play this are you doing what's this what the fuck we got the
pokemon lego here we got the root fucking ruby red pokemon
what wait these are all game mods
rare hello I didn't realize we were doing this
what for deep in the forest built a thriving theme park in a large cleared area to have 250
guests in your park at the end of October year one with a park rating of 600
is this gonna crash my pc at me the first roller coaster with 10 in versions investors
inversions I think that means investors right how do I pause oh my god this is not right you know
so don't show me help okay maybe show me help a little bit oh my god I thought this was going
to come back to me instantly I guess not
hello hello oh my god who said who said pick this game what is this right okay here's a buy
stop oh is this right oh my god this is a mistake this stream I can tell you that much
inversion when you're outside 10 um right hold on okay first people need to eat and drink
we need to charge extortionate prices okay next
uh we're not doing both new thrills that's it everyone get on how to rotate oh
shit are for rotate nope that would be too logical uh w a i've just made the game
absolutely fucking tidy how the fuck do I rotate this like with this one oh no I see
oh god
here's your new park hold the rate most button to drag and view and see the whole part no
well and then I just make a path right make a path right let's make a path
what the fuck is this oh no oh yeah mr crabs what's this
oh no don't they need a little house I'm so sorry the stream's too scoff to continue good
night I'm I'm too embarrassed to continue let's just say it's a musketeer I'm too embarrassed
to continue unironically wait wasn't there do you not have to put a little house outside the rides
do I not I could have sworn you have to put a little hot outside a ride I am oh yeah mr crabs
you have to put a little tiki hut or something you do I knew it I knew it
oh everything's gonna be fucking south fate like oh west facing it won't work without an entrance
and exit oh dear lord who said play this game it was me but who's right stop giving me hints
I know I should be reading that guy but no I'm sorry right this is scenery right so fencing
and shite won't come under that but this
what are you
the ride never ends it'll allow you constantly guests can't get on it making a veiler theme
but are you joking I can't even get the bloody thing oh I can't even figure out how to put an
entrance in I just need oh god the game's so quiet I just realized you can't like hear nothing in the
game um burger right it's not landscaping go away it's not the monorail something's in development
you'll need to give me a second give me the cheesy feet here like like like gaming kiss
uni you're done for mod's time that manner and I'm just I'm so sorry it's normal to not have music
yet makes an enthusiastic coaster it comes from the rides when it's played oh my god
the euthanasia coaster I just reread that I'm sorry she said euthanasia oh my god right this is
embarrassing am I gonna oh my god right I'm actually looking up I'm sorry right what we're playing
roller coaster tycoon where is the fucking open and closed 10 I'm literally typing that in right
now where's the open and closed 10 she said the enthusiastic cost I can't even read right right
it has to be in game don't it has to be in the passing but why not why would it not be in the
passing oh who did that can you control z oh you absolutely cannot control we don't get too excited
now if it's the same it's where you click on the ride and before that's the most right I've clicked
on the ride right right okay mm-hmm play music fuck yeah that's fine I didn't want to hear it anyway
oh you right okay this is the building
how can I I just can't am I actually this like I know I'm special I'm not being funny I know I'm
special I've accepted that it took me many years plain entrance please
one plain one wooden entrance but on the first tab
uh-huh the crane entrance uh-huh can't construct there's a footpath right oh we're
okay first we must destroy the footpath how do I destroy a footpath
there must oh for fuck's sake now we need to find the builders until any builders hey I found a
builder you you wait footpath what okay okay okay don't hurt him now oh oh my god this place is
astronomically so big wait what's that this is a secret oh sorry wait why did it cost me to
remove the tree someone can sell that for fuel right hold on let me finish my tea this is awful
I needed a short game and I was like oh yeah I played that once before I'm sure that'll be fine
it gets absolutely obliterated right so that's the front and that's okay let's do the back
right uh-huh then let's do a path right okay and then this is the exit okay now we can do it
right we've done that so now we just need to open up how is it closed how do I open you
pirate ship no queue
the park is closed right let's open up the park park closed look open it up with a red flag park open
the thing open okay okay mr crab how do I keep doing that
how am I so it's not WASD's move oh it's why would it be that that's awful don't ever do that again
right um overview yes I would like one entrance
uh-huh and I would like one exit uh-huh and then I would like to add even more paths so we'll just
make this like a weird thing uh assume that's correct yeah yeah right we have two attractions
open now once I open it I will figure out how to open it like okay oh yeah
okay now so the people this is absolutely awful don't ever let me pick this game
did you open the park I did it's called frontier oh it's called forest frontiers
wait the park is so close no it's open park got open days
the ship is closed oh it is what the heck why is it closed oh it's doing a test run
are you scooting me right now no way inspector craig and this park is horrible and small I
wouldn't recommend it how dare you your accusations right it's doing a test run can you just like I
don't know ship the people that are waiting what do you mean a test run
there's like no ambience do this oh I made a dollar fitty I ain't complaining
they cost so much to enter them every ride has such a street long way craig is back on his
flight oh is it craig not craig sorry craig inspector craig how could I be so sorry right
so then what I just extend the path and keep going okay oh wait don't you not need to put like
rubbish bins down or something or people will litter everywhere are you you are you're a little
also rubbish bin I will put the bins everywhere right everyone why are you going up the path
there's nothing up there I'm getting trolled I'm getting trolled I'm getting trolled
I'm getting trolled right a merry-go-round oh yeah mr crabs the entrance I will put it
yeah and the exit I will put it yeah this is the worst part construction ever
I'm so sorry no more backseat just want to help with game layout oh no you're getting absolutely
do not look if you're like an actual legit gamer of this game do not look don't look it's
it's not going well right test run oh wait what stop test running what the heck get on the frick
open up what the I don't really test runs weren't like okay we've done the test let's go next no the
test runs like permanent okay sorry geez right who wants food food glorious food
wait the ice cream shop isn't open you have to manually open up the ice cream shop
it's just sitting there and people are thirsty and dehydrated oh shit people need to literally
shit forgot about that that they need toilets and stuff hold on hold on right okay let's put a
random toilet up here see you have to hate that oh you have to open the toilet no what all right
I need what do I need a handyman sure gives me one of you no what can I just hire you
no do not mow the grass sweep the footpaths don't water the gardens and empty the litter bins
and sweep the path that'll do hire oh shit there's two of them is that the merry-go-round
making that horrific song what are you mechanic I'm a weekend what gender are you I'm a mechanic
what are you security guard oh my god ready
right okay oh my god check us out right we're doing it we're doing it hold on we've got 64 guests
come on you can change the music okay let me finish this tea right hold on
all right all right all right okay okay okay now hold on it's coming back to me it's not
but we can make it work what are you twist riders pair okay shout out to all my peers
stop that stop it's such an old meme I don't know why I keep saying that so what entrance oh my god
I'm doing it though sorry but we're investing so this is actually the alluring get it
right no test everyone just jump on we're not testing this stuff out oh we made a dollar oh
we're making dollars we're making dollars over like 300 freaking how much was that
so we did the the twist it cost us like 300 but we're making dollars wait we can already buy
what we can already buy one of these the mango muncher why does that sound
well you know viola land literally oh my wait I can have I can just straight up have this
I'm allowed this like off the bat I'm allowed this
this is such a terrible theme park there's just one massive ride and then like all these
baby rides right at the start oh my god oh my god great let's get more great let me do this
let me do the entrance oh I had to
I need the entrance yeah no select entrance location I can't see nothing
that's the entrance there it's already got one oh already comes with one oh my god use your eyes
the lines right if I do that I can't just straight up open it
this theme park makes no sense just oh by the way we have like a mega coaster
you can build a coaster yourself oh I've never done it because it never works out I get so
confused with the like angle and stuff right okay we need to let people sit down people need
to sit down how do I get benchy oh no being decoration sorry right let's give people a
sweet mirror right now who goes there I have come to make a suggestion change your company name from
valetierpola to be more realistic about the girl's most prevalent skill yeah I think it works
I Karen he messaged I talked to the manager this park only has four rides and I don't
like any of them also my ice cream and it was way too cold actually real though because they're
always freaking like that really this is a problem and it's like what are you on about what do you
mean it's a problem be for real things right how right we need more food because we all know
that parks like hella aren't charging me right now because so which bathroom can I get relieved in
thank you for this hit man on and Karen and tiny spiny yaffa lure honestly it's better than
peeler I'm just glad cackler hasn't started and it better or not it better or not I better not come
online and someone's like one of the girls just dropped the cutest dookie dot mp3 audio you should
totally do it yourself Ronnie I mean excuse me dookie mp3 audio what do you mean what are you
saying right I need more toilets because people need the toilet I need the toilet just looking
at this park lay out right before you go on the ride you can go for a shite okay you're welcome
oh my god wait can you not charge people oh my god I'm charging you 10 cents to go for a dookie
wait did I say running cost running cost pair I was pretty squid me right now
scrawny since you started streaming I only can work with your voice on the background
so I'm giving you this tip for being such a good girl I'm making you more productive
oh get productive get productive get productive whilst you affect my reproductive reproductive
thank you so much PV I'm so glad I can help you focus up on
stuff and keep you keep you motivated keep you motivated everything has an operation speeder
free bathrooms you're a monster bro they start charging oh my god I have a gripe I have a gripe
with Edinburgh train station actually it's probably in Glasgow's train stations and I've just never had
to think earlier before fucking went to Edinburgh train station and the thing's like Gia's a quid
or you're no going for a piss and I'm like excuse me Gia you a quid or I can't even relieve my bowels
you'll make a piss on the floor what's going on here what's actually going on here like the audacity
to charge for the actually sorry mate the audacity to charge also me in the video game he he 20 cents
for that shopping but look I've got business to run actually are we even making a profit with how
much I don't know are we making profit I mean it kind of looks like it we've got a thousand so we
can't buy anything more free toilets what are you European unbelievably do the Chad moving piss
on the floor in front of the bathroom truly the only way to make make a change be the change you
want to see let's just do you want me to be on the floor it is Glasgow train station you know what
right Glasgow's not that bad Glasgow isn't that bad okay it's a nice city you might get stabbed
but you'll get instructions on the way to the hospital right before anyone thinks I made that
joke up I stole that joke it's a very famous joke before any of you are like hold on a minute
streamer you're actually kind of mildly funny I have whoa everyone's loving this ride
oh wait the closer you go the louder the screams are but the far away you are you can't hear nothing
I'm used to getting charged 50 cents for a pee
that's outrageous it's amazing that she finds something she genuinely hates her accent comes
out and descends to Scottish rage real true I told my dad since Tottenham that I've been
I've noticed that I've got a little bit more like Scottish twang to me when he's here because he
has a much stronger accent than me here in the short um but he has a much stronger accent than
I did is anyone being sick oh get that cleaned up where's my Johnny's
so like location
well the footpath for one go clean up your minger wait
he'll only do those tails no that can't be right
don't don't do that no he need no undo whatever you're doing whatever you're doing undo it
right do not be stuck on that path in or that's literally up
whoo no he's fine he's fine he's fine he's fine right okay it's fine it's fine
that was I really did not want him to do that wages $50 per month that's more than except
right so what was my objective I forgot but if it's 30 I don't want to see if I can
guarantee a clean toilet oh yeah real to be honest I think it's not brain happy
I'm glad I'm sorry it's so skill but at the same time
hold on I need to turn this down a little bit I turned it down just a teeny tiny bit
I noticed at the start of my streaming I didn't realize how much I had to turn down the game sound
I have to all my games are played at like negative like 10 11 decibels type thing
and you can build a coaster now oh god oh damn for your really challenging me though but I've
never done one how does it right hold on monorail no that can't be it
oh there's a racetrack I just saw that new raid attraction looping roller coaster do not tempt me
fellow temptress hold on hold on what wait I've not unlocked it haunted house fairs wheel
merry go round car spiral new roller coaster junior 30 designs available uh the people post on reddit
their builds are insane you know what give me a thing I'm gonna I'm gonna show you something
how does anyone right hold on let me show you the screenshot this is absolutely batshit insane
how right okay so POV I'm too scared to build my own roller coaster all right and then this is a
this is what I see
how do you know what's going on is this the same coaster okay can we just pretend this is my park
for a second though like for real for real I'm so successful how how how can you even see what
you're doing I don't I do different claw roller coasters it must be look at the path then but
like there's no benches for the people the smallest grid and can do and overlay and everything
where's the star it's just blinding there's some autistic talent right there pat pat there's so
much autistic talent in here
it's my party
okay right right uh we've not unlocked out sorry I've completely just zoned out there I apologize
uh I don't know what happened there I just stopped talking that was really odd please don't do that
again that made me uncomfortable um sorry I don't know how long I was quiet for but I literally was
like hmm where you this of course right I don't think we can actually manually build a roller
coaster yet you know that I think we actually can wooden roller coaster junior and look this game
is for tizm kings and queens honestly real true we love it oh I can rotate right go do the haunted
mansion yeah haunted mansion time right you and you oh but I'm getting so good at that oh this is
oh that's like messing with me the rotation but it makes sense that it will take okay and then rotate
again and then again okay and then do that okay and then open okay so do we now have a haunted
mansion we're down to 800 dollars we're cutting it pretty low not gonna lie not gonna lie it's
getting pretty low hope these marbles is affordable are those screams of death are the folk flying off
the roller coaster wait how does it go oh I would go on this roller coaster if it doesn't go upside
down or like make me violently ill then I think I could manage the g-force on this part this little
cylindrical are you guys gonna oh there's two carts at a time all right okay so when that one docks
that one gets ready to go okay build your best death trap coaster I'm sure I've read a meme about
some guy you can have a park right next to like another AI part and they had to like out do it and
the way they did it was they threw a coaster off into their park and the game registered it as a coaster
day um on the other part and it like plummeted their numbers or something are those screams of joy
or dread you have to find out yourself I scream on the other coasters I said what I said okay I scream
on coaster that's right your name's coaster I'll be screaming that's all right it's too easy stopping
right so wait we have 300 guests at a time
if I'm park rating it went down and then it went up okay
guests in park wait does that need 600 at one time the admission price is free wait I could be
making so much smack a reason to have at least 250 guests in your park at the end of October
where are we date wise I have no idea I actually oh you can get a war
real free 99 more like
thank you thank you I scream on coaster and then I'm coaster oh okay wait so
okay okay tell you oh I can't even change it oh the game maybe the game dictates what your
entry fee is gonna be I mean I think we're doing okay a little scuffed out in the middle of nowhere
but uh down and up then I thought we were talking about the game not how we have to
he's there as bad as me man you got a food stall right in front of the bathroom as well
what you don't want to eat and shit really efficiently like literally
home boom home boom home boom why is that usually it's enough right there better be
no vomit on these paths I haven't inspected them in a while uh maybe I should have one
one janitor constantly out here
yeah I would just get him to do that right don't water the gardens I couldn't be left of a shite
right can we even invest in anything more I don't even know how to tell
what time it is
okay no one's in the haunted mansion yeah they are wait twist one why is no one on twist
well that guy's waiting queuing for twist yeah there's one guy for why do you guys keep going
up the path are you squidding me right now why do you keep going up mommy can you say I love
food a few times fast tiny sweeney thank you I love food uh oh you're done you're done I know
exactly what you're trying to get me to say because of my accent are you joking are you wait did you
just figure that out right now or is that like a thing that all vtubers can do it stop wait is that
is that my accent or can all vtubers do that
only you whoa because I don't say t's you are special oh my god is that my mom in chat
oh my god the grass is so overgrown how how are we gonna survive just you literally got me thank
you tiny spiny that was creative I have to admit that was creative I could be that god our park is
thriving with vomit everywhere do I need to hire more janitors
or is it castodia oh that's fucking boggin right we need a hell of a lot more holy moly moly
that is disgusting what are you doing
uh go clean that oh why is everyone but relax stop vomiting there's a toilet right there go
pre vomit my goodness that is boggin don't don't do that again I don't know for getting another
rollercoaster they just vomit whenever you know vomit on the grass like literally lean over the
balcony and puke on the grass the the animals will be happy the wildlife will be a static
you should charge them per vomit real I'll charge them for a hanky per vomit what why are you here
go go help clean up oh no he did clean up the bomb okay I'm sorry the vomit is going it's going
going on no it's not what the heck please anyone you come get rocked on wait how do I make sure
he's not under the map it's cleaning no I'm just watching him puke I just saw him puke
but the rollercoaster isn't that it's one twirl it's literally one twirl I think you can add benches
to get people to calm down they're bloody orbs or give me a bench right now right everyone sit
down do you understand me sit down after the rollercoaster just chill oh wait I can put like
benches as we get off I didn't even know that right sit down everyone sit down relax and then
we'll put some bins along the way too I guess hold on I can like hardly see what I'm trying to achieve
nope bin yep no puke in the bins puke in the bins hold on this is like you can't believe it we need
to be pixel perfect boom in the bin oh everyone sit down and stop how do you and I sick man
man I love counting pixels damn straight you do this is a classic I don't even know when this game
was produced oh did you see that ghost from the window do it again do it again there's a ghost that
came out of this window here benches reduce nausea and without bins they will drop garbage on the ground
I mean oh like there's two now they're they're doing the thing oh like I see you
you can drown people in this damper of course you would know that
by the way you can do commit mass murder in a theme park damper
damper you're supposed to say that part of it Danny changed the pathing type they're like
I don't know what they're expecting to think oh he's got food in his hand
apparently their original game was made by one person which is pretty
insane if you think about it new attraction and information kiosk how is that how is that an
attraction how is that an attraction a stall where guests can obtain maps and purchase umbrellas oh
oh another another profit you see okay can we open you up right away yeah a map is 60 cents
and an umbrella is 250 but well hopefully she's just giving you good of it yeah the guy made
everything himself in the weirdest coding language but if he did wait yeah yeah it was it was a one
man army and he went absolutely uh just out the wazoo with it he did fantastic
I see all the power to him
right there's no don't do it don't you puke on the pathway the twister has broken down right
call the mechanic call the mechanic where's the mechanic mechanic you calipers
go to the right where are you going do you need to go the other way
no go fix the right walking where
her
answering radio call wait how detailed is this game responding to the twister broken
what that's so cool thank you broly legend for the super chat as well
okay it's fixing it all right all right what's the walking
wait we have a freaking analysis avon your damn shells avon avon queuing for mango muncher
sitting because he feels sick oh i just zoomed all the way out oh this is rather walking mango
muncher queuing sitting heading
yeah there's not much queues for the other stuff everyone wants the big freaking roller coaster
i love the cheeseburger stems if you click on them you can see their name and what they're thinking
oh they're hungry
wait there's one hunger there one hunger there oh god do you even know that burger
stand i think we do uh let's just shove it right here so you can't miss it i don't want anyone
saying i'm hungry
how much are we making on the profit per item sold at all the review okay next one
everyone's queuing a strone's mango yeah click on them looking at the thoughts is how you can
figure out what potential issues you can address are you thinking i'm not hungry well that will
be in reflection carrying nothing cash in pocket cash spent paid zero to enter the part how's the
charge for the part entropy even if i can charge 10 cents it would make all the difference
you know what you know what video game you're showing
reading their puny minds honest questions are another place you could stream for once a week
and that comes out next august august first are we almost in august first we're almost there
august first the girl's going to be streaming on bensley i'm not really sure how long my streams
are going to last to be honest it'll be like 10 minutes and then we're off oh that's kind of
if it's kind of true it'll just be yeah for the first ages who is putting rubbish on the ground
on up to
who is littering in my park who is littering in my park you understand me don't do that
hi
everyone sit down if you're not feeling well just sit down you're not going to miss anything
sit down there's nothing to miss this park is a really really big place you're not going to
miss anything for being awake and saying
it was me am i getting punished for it please letter bugs how do you is this a german park
why would it be a german park wait what makes it look german
when bam thank you ma'am hi
10 you mean two minutes how do you at least let me ramble first okay
come comically fast gang we're so in stop you need to hire staff to maintain us i need more
i think i do i think i've lost too much
i said he's walking
can i see him
where is he
i just said select location for these two
i don't know just pop you down was there two that were like oh no one of them i passed at the
the vomit and quarry i don't know
if they all walk around i don't mind right there's no point in having him stuck at the
oh no i don't want to sack him he's got a wife and kids you know right i want to take him off
of the walking thing though i don't want him to be on a path
okay
don't be on the path okay he's not on it anymore no he is he's still blue
i don't undo it right sorry you're getting stuck
can't i can't figure out how to tell him to not have that pathway so he's just getting the sack
sorry but okay we're gonna hire more
select no don't don't do any gardening or fry
this is like location but
where are you
surely this time
i don't call them surely
oh everyone just go and do your thing
wiley coyote thank you for coming to member well yeah there's bends everywhere don't be a litter
bug you need to hire more
yeah i think we've got more than enough to cover the park numbers maybe there's like a
super good miracle
excuse me the mango monsher is nice and all but when do we get the peach penetrator
real true okay wait can i read if i oh no i only have eight dollars holy do i need to put the prices up
all right i'm i'm just gonna go out on a limb and say that i'm not allowed to
charge more
i think i'm gonna have to start up in my prices i've become i've become the very thing i swore
to destroy we have a hundred bucks profit per hour minus right get that off
profit per hour that's more like it a hundred and thirty two dollars per hour profit right hold
on let's look at the profit profit a hundred and eighteen what about you profit
two hundred right that's good i want everything making a profit
capital for everything i swore to destroy what do you make five hundred bucks
oh it's raining or is it bedtime everyone go home nope it's raining okay
you either have a high entrance fee and cheap rides or no entrance fee and expensive rides
whoa are we making umbrella sales
we're making umbrella sales 600 bucks because it rains
and there we even thought about that but yeah theme parks must be i hope no one has epilepsy
by the way do not watch that's making 200 quid an hour
total profit almost two grand so it's not it's almost paid itself off
the little umbrellas are so cute little brawlys
hello little brownie that's when umbrella is in slang it's me brawly you got your brawly with
you mommy you're supposed to destroy the high table not join them i know but satisfying game money
cool oh i can't handle it the voices
this game was my childhood i hope you're having fun i'm having fun by going to thank you for this
super chat it is fun i played it like over the span of two days but i was quite young
i couldn't really remember it the twist we keep breaking down oh dear you only have one mechanical
on the thing um someone is getting struck by lightning wait can you can people die in this game
new ride a log flume
oh i'm putting 200 quid into funding as well can you go bankrupt if you go into the negative
or does the game not give a shit um a thousand i don't have a thousand but what would be our next
investment maybe another coaster although ferris wheel is really cute i'm just gonna do ferris
wheel okay well buy the ferris wheel when we get enough brah we're losing every time i'm like oh we've
got 200 but very asset mango munchers going up i'm i can't idea mango munch okay well rename the
next roller coaster we get but wait no yeah okay put this up because clearly people are enjoying it
i'm sorry but we need the money i can't put it i don't know how to put it yeah i'm brailing it to
20 dollars is the matter stop that's terrible you can join them or they can die from a crashing
roller coaster yes they can and it tanks your rating oh my rain bear how is my park not like a
hundred percent rain sorry but literally admission is free go to literally any other park oh no it is
oh no that's guessing park sorry we wavered a little at the end of august apparently it's better
work situation as you say okay one rule of thumb is you can match the price with the excitement
ring oh yeah i knew that i knew that
the liability downtime lasting section inflection over 30 minutes
okay okay okay okay here i'm i'm i'm i'm exciting rating high high and nausea ratings medium
meet jump wait this guy went all out max negative vertical g guess there's thirsty and can't find
anywhere to buy a drink um one you're lying two i don't have the money for that
my god i'm so sorry i'm actually gonna have to put prices up how is my profit down right everyone
pays two dollars for a ride in two dollars to take a dookie your choice
please put my profit off i'm begging i'm begging begging you hey stroney does this park have any
sort of drinks that increase energy and isn't insanely sugary you're getting fizzy just and
you're gonna like it you're getting mummy's fizzy right a drink i still don't have enough for drinks
what am i doing so terribly wrong in the park that just literally need to hate all the prices up
people can't find a drinking peeler oh my god i'm playing this game terribly right everything's
going up right a dollar fifty try that dollar fifty go for it because this is getting outrageous
i'm needing profits mummy needs profits i demand my shareholders get everything
and the people get nothing total profit minus seven bucks right get that hiked up as well then
minus seven freaking dollars wait so that one's like way more popular oh it's showing me individually
she missed the chance to plug gamer subs oh use code stroney for 10 percent off gamer subs don't
forget to smash that like subscribe button and and watch my newest short and leave a comment and
be like wow vtubers make so much money i'm quitting my job don't quit your job but you know if you
leave a comment ring that bell and make sure you fart and for a good healthy digestive tract or
something like that right i'm trying to give you the liquids but i keep having to pay people's
wages and stuff there we go boom right everyone i'm hiking that price up saving all the part
two dollars for a drink i don't care right now you guys can't complain about being thirsty
what are your thoughts whilst you cube bobby it i can just legally rename someone
i can just rename someone no it's true wow rippling you're about to fucking perish from your your
thirst
you're actually about to perish from your thirst
everyone like mega dehydrated there is a drink stall at the start oh wait there's only one oh no
wait that's not a drink stall this is the only drink stall i hate that profits per item sold
170 on fissures drinks is close right hold on let's wait everyone get get hydrated get hydrated
get hydrated give them two dollars yes yes i want to see them dollars rolling in
and then we might be a successful part graph that meant we're cutting it close
we're negative 22 bucks what do we need another roller coaster
whoa what was that show me that statistic again do that again
huh cashless loan have i got a loan
wait am i paying a loan
a loan
a loan of what
i'm not a loan interest
shop stall we didn't drink stalls
right instructions and cost right we didn't spend in october
oh my god what did they do to the ui
company values there so am i getting shanked sorry
this how did my park value go down when i've done nothing but add to it
oh we can do marketing campaign vouchers for free rates on a particular rate
vouchers for free food and drink does that work though
maybe i need a lake guests are complaining because you can't find the toilet what do you mean
there's toilets everywhere there's one right outside that right right we'll put one right here
then i guess please wait did i forget to turn it on i did no it's on right there's a toilet there
there's a toilet there there's a toilet there so what are you all like caca and yourself or
something you can't find toilet i find that hard to believe me i really do i actually do
have anybody
maybe the toilets are struggling to find you i don't know there seems to be some sort of
some sort of common theme going on running ads is actually really good uh how did i get back
to that page that was on oh this one advertising campaign 350 per week i don't even think i have
maybe free vouchers tight do it on ice cream start the campaign
come on come on they're just this place must smell lovely literally get your hot dogs get your
hot dogs and someone's like letting out the most nastiest absolutely reeking shite of their life
they're fighting for themselves in that toilet and all you hear is like their farts echoing off the
back windows whilst you're like picking up your burger here like literally like
hydration check little reflux well as peeler
i get to make azure's unathon thing soon and i'm so tempted to slip in peeler audio
for a certain money amount i need her approval on it i need her approval before i get in trouble
inspector craig one drink stand i'm writing a health violation inspector you have to understand
i am running on like zero profit i cannot figure out how to um like hike the price up in the park
i don't know if i need to close it and then i could change it no right i open the park sorry
i don't know how to change the price i think maybe it's locked in the first map
just to give you an indication what you need to do inspector craig please i'm trying so hard
what am i maybe sorry someone said umbrella method umbrella price shove that shit up
uh right let's do this just put it up to five dollars put a map up to like two dollars
because i'm dying i'm dying of financial death i can't even do it
i don't know if people are gonna be teased though if i actually do that
i love all the umbrellas whoa this is so sweet and then
more drinks stands would allow you to sell more drinks i can't believe it you mean improving
so i put a drink here so what do i want to put a drink like here
oh i can't cost it i can't pay for it until right now boom so open
open sesame right you all better start drinking
and for praise tonight we're gonna start drinking and one person's gonna get that reference to you
my daughter would hate this place oh no oh my god you're a pixel on the fucking
profile pictures oh that's amazing hey um my kid got chopped in half on that right over there can
you help me out uh fun brellas only 20 if it gets added to the do nothing we will definitely
get six out of six yeah you can choose what colors umbrellas are and the information's
then can i make them go in that's not the information then this is the information
sign boom just like that just like that refunds look like refund customers pair our popularity
satisfaction map sold what are your thoughts i'm not paying that much for a mark cap oh wrong
way around other one for a mark cap for a park map jay sorry for your names mark
you're like what did i do sorry or me i'm sorry
i've been i actually have a short when i tried to say thank you for the 10 gifted memberships
um i'm gonna post this very shortly
okay well um i'm posting it shortly and it's literally me going thank you for the kids
wait actually i might have i might be able to play the audio on stream of it
i need to be careful i need to be careful i'm about to come no stop sorry i'm i'm right hold on
oh rustic thank you for the again again but
try again thank you rustic for the gentifted mentorship
what hello rustic thank you so much for the gifted 10 memberships to the channel thank you
i really appreciate that and congrats to those who caught it with your face what was that i'm
taking it yeah basically i had a stroke and not the good king
okay jeez okay okay i'm fine
marks reproductive health is important in cervical cancer's note we support mark's
tab oh we did it by accident deep in the forest filled the thriving your objective
heavily 250 guests in your park at the end of october you achieve a company value enter your name
no it's fine um we did it right what happens now
wait one guy coded all of this this is insane right what was over here i swear there's something
over here bro he literally put in so much detail to like put someone living out in the woods in
in the back like is there like more secrets in this map or is it just that
maybe oh it's just the type of tree that looks different how can one
he built it in a cave with a box of scraps right how do we go on to the next game
i'm pressing escape but actually nothing happened
i don't how do i get how do i get out i'm stuck i want to i'm actually stuck um i'm
pressing escape but nothing happened aim for map oh guests are complaining canny fane toilets and
they need drinks right well yes we're good well done you have access to a new park scenario
in the graphite group diamond types okay how did i get out of here
am i stuck step coaster i'm stuck i'm actually stuck no like for real i'm pressing escape but
it's not like popping off a menu like i know these games are old but i don't realize there
was that freaking old release me is it is it the lower left that's rage footpath trees here
oh my god i'm actually stuck i was gonna do another scenario there isn't the remake menus are worse
oh yeah there's something underneath her oh there it what oh hold on
you know how i was like how can you tell what time of year is my fat ass was covering up okay right
so if i click wait i guess quit old progress since your last save okay so save it yes you're safe
and then quit because we're gonna go play the same oh that's really bright okay so we're gonna
start a new park dynamite june no it's awful leafy lake have 500 guests at the park diamond types
achieve a value of 300 thousand relax i'm literally not like it to have at least 750
yes you're the park great in 600 right i'll do that one that one seems we'll do emerald
that one okay did you know right pause let's look at what the status is we've got okay i need to do
these q things okay i'm learning i'm learning right let's analyze it what are those are those
are those british houses
oh my god sorry the developer puts so much love into this game he was bothered enough on his
arse to make hooses and like places where they're thinking mummies are so big it's smothering the
concept of time literally this stream gave me a base crush gives you the gluck gluck in the tunnel
that that's no no that's not that is some more influence works strutty yeah reef one
which one is yours i don't live in a house like this are you don't look at that beach
house in here look at that beach house in here any British houses right oh there's a beat oh wait
it's a beach side hmm right okay first things first let's get
why can i not have charge admission why do i need permission to charge admission
as a british feel offended it's actually very developed literally there's a big massive coaster
you might be able to buy some buildings on there wait we're gonna demolish family homes in the
name of expansion that's pretty cool right have we got any food or drink not that i can visually see
there's no food and drink right let's deal with that before we get in trouble a chip shop
i that's the most british thing you could ask for for as soon as you end no stop right and then
hate them motherfucking prices up make it two dollars for chips welcome to the real world mother
everything is charged out that and then drinks yep can't get more british than that
a little drink a syringe enter two dollars for drinks pause okay okay we are gonna and then we
want an information kiosk boom just like that pause no i'm not ready yet put the map up to a dollar
put the broilies up to three okay what else do we need what else do we need we need a toilet
so everyone can go for a job at home and then let's charge out the arse for it literally let's
charge you to release your arse okay there's a pun in there but i can't figure it out okay the next
next we need nothing because we've covered all the basic okay we are gonna put two shitters over
here as well though i do not trust park guests not to like just fucking shit themselves i like
some of the horror stories i hear about theme parks is like fully grown adults just shitting
themselves rather like because they're like oh we couldn't find the bathroom so i shat myself and
it's like what do you want to rephrase that again i don't understand what you've just communicated
to me it's like i shat myself um what do you mean what do you why didn't you go to the toilet
oh it took too long it took too long what took too long oh the toilet the toilet i took it
what i could never what the heck are the one guy built this oh my gosh
real
no
what on earth um well i certainly haven't got the price tag for any of those but it says
ones 2,800 who's 2,800 who's 2,800 where's rick don't care where's rick
2,800 2,800 2,800 i don't see it
It's shown me fears that don't, some people really are grown children, real true, um,
modern real cycles, special bicycle runs on a steel motor track propelled by the peddle
of the rider.
Oh that looks fun, oh my god sorry I would go on that, excitement rating, how is that
one less?
Why is that one more?
Intensity and thingy, well this one is cheaper and has more excitement rating, so who am
I to stop him, right, now let's actually do the proper passing okay, oh wait it already
has a proper queue, oh man I love the pre-built stuff, are you joking, I literally don't even
have to think, I love it, right open and charge a bit more, ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
What about you, where's the, is this the entrance?
It's four dollars per roller coaster ride, what about you?
Carousel, let's bump you up to a dollar, um, wheel, wheel, let's bump you up by 50 cent,
okay and then go, or should I just buy another coaster, I've got 2300, I'm tempted, but these
are all like low water tricycles, peddle tricycles with large buoyant wheels, oh no absolutely
not, I'm not doing any of that, don't ask me to do that again, observation tower, nope
what the heck, right, bump votes, single circular ding, dingies powered by central motor, no
I'm not custom building anything, I'm too scared okay, the pre-builds were safe but
they eventually become too boring for the intents, the extra 50 cents on the wheel cost
is to cover clean up from all the handies, what is going on, right, I don't, a monorail,
a miniature railway, I am not custom building anything, I do not trust myself, right, these
are going to be too boring I think, miniature railway, monorail, custom design layer, right,
I guess we'll just do it from there and save up for, save up for, that's a scream out of
nowhere, let's see what the guests are thinking, this park map from in is really good, I'm
not hungry, okay but what do you guys from over here think, I feel sick, sit down, sit,
down, sit down, sit down, no not that one, not that one, everyone sit down that gets off of
this roller coaster, do I make myself clear, do I make myself clear, sit down, stop pooping,
I don't have enough money for janitors yet, sit down, no do not puke, orange, don't puke,
sit down, don't do it, don't do it, don't do it, go to the bathroom, go to the bathroom,
you're sick, you're sicking yourself, do I need to put a toilet outside the thing, if I put a
toilet surely, if I put a toilet, and we can charge people for you to puke, right, ha let's get,
I'm a mechanic, let's get, I've only got, you better stop watering anything, but one guy,
we should hire a mechanic and just have him on table, fix ride inspector, yep that's all good
with me, or all good with me, entertainer, no, I'll get another handyman though, because
we might need a few to walk the length of the park, don't you dare water the grass young man,
no way she said I'm a mechanic, entertainer, hardly even know her, come on guys please give me an
ounce of anything, when you come up with this hilarious, but if I repeat it, apparently it's
not funny anymore, I'm a handyman too, shiny, are you sad that the 3d0 omni is no longer available,
what is that one, is that the white one, the main one, what's the omni, POV veiler, get, end up
getting a house and then we can all share the KU100 together, that's probably the only way I'll
ever justify such an upgrade, I don't think I can utilize it properly, has a terrible fun,
pun you should be ashamed of yourself, the one with four ears, ew, I never looked at the one with
four ears, did I open this, I did, wait, that's the ride, oh that is so cute, reeflings you have
to take me on this raid, I'd actually really want to do it, sorry but the smack kind of thing, I
want to look at all the flowers as they feel a little drive-by, a little fountain going on, that's
so cute, oh there's like giraffes, oh this is so cute, you have to do it, that KU100 me, all six
of us jumping here at the same time, could you handle the table, would take you on that raid,
it's so cute, look at all the tulips, oh look at the waterbees as well,
why are you okay, oh he's watching the big depper, big depper is really good value, big depper,
could that just say what I think I said, the park is really clean and tidy, okay I'm glad,
carrying a map, I think, yeah I think I said what I think I said, which I didn't expect, what are
you doing, oh you're looking at a map, well you did help these like reeflings, it's been a while
since I've had some relief so you know, get ready for Twitter, so when I've caught up on my work and
I don't feel stressed, let me go for it, oh the Ferris wheel to get a view of the beach is so pretty,
okay, are we making a profit, although I'm getting nervous,
is there only one of those,
everyone walking, no not everyone walking up to the Ferris wheel, only to walk away again,
they're like no we're not in traffic, sorry, okay people actually seem to like the mehorse thing,
people are digging the Ferris wheel, get in, big wheel is good value, I want to get off big wheel,
you're in queue for it,
big wheel is really good value, big depper looks too intense, I'm not hungry, big wheel is good value,
how about no,
Galapurs was great, oh that must be the name of the other ride,
that ride low-key fire, I've never been on these before,
so in Scotland it's called The Shows,
oh the one big stretch, it's called The Shows, I mean the Shows are in town, it's like these
kind of rides that they build up, like obviously it's built from park, I mean every ride is built
from a park, but it gets like built up and dropped every other week, and I'm like too scared to
actually ever ride anything from The Shows, I don't know if the signs actually do anything,
what sign, this sign, this expansion,
maybe, your park has received an award for being the tidiest park,
oh thank you, thank you I did it all myself, wait they're taking pictures of the ride,
I don't even think about that,
like if you put up no interest signs, they do work, my son died on a roller coaster, oh no
Inspector Craig I'm so sorry, and oh my god that would be your story, your son died on a ride,
so then you vowed to become an inspector of parks, so that it would never happen to anyone
else's son again, but it never, it doesn't matter how many rides you inspect and get
sorted out and people that you theoretically saved, it never fills the void of the emptiness that
your son left behind, so sad, that's honestly so sad, your park's so tidy, you're working your way
up to the safest park in the country, let's go, whoa that is so, the stuff writes itself,
no entry signs specifically do work because that's coded in option, I'm gonna fart so I need to mute
I did multiple farts in one, I like how I had to tab out in order to do that as well,
so just everything went silent, even the game went silent to hear my fart,
whoo, it's fucking Rekin, that's going straight up, that's going straight up my nostrils, fuck off,
it's fucking minging, what's wrong with me, what did I eat yesterday,
what did I eat, I can't even remember, oh I had, I ordered full for the first time,
but I don't, I don't know, I ordered chicken full and I don't think you're supposed to have
chicken, it's supposed to be beef and it was absolutely minging, I'm sorry but I don't know
if they completely messed it up and they were making fun of me or something because that was
absolutely Rekin, it was disgusting and everyone on TikTok makes it look like the most delicious
thing ever and I'm like ew, I found it rather vile, so yeah, betrayed by your own, perhaps death
by your own fart, damn it, I smell like popcorn over there, how dare you use my, my scriptures
against me, are we investing again something, junior roller coaster, okay that's what I need,
I need to invest in more roller coasters and then I'll just hike the prices up,
do you like baked potatoes, I absolutely do them for their pog champs,
baked potato, I've actually been having shrimp with them because I'm trying to eat more fish
because apparently it helps with your longevity and I'm like hmm, okay fine, where are these,
see these guests are actually having to walk like a freaking mile just to get into the park,
but we'll definitely, when that roller coaster comes up, we'll definitely be saving and spending,
have you seen the potato with the beans and cheese, damn pot, I'm so sure I'll break this
too but I'm from Scotland and we do, we share a lot of culture with the rest of Britain, yes,
I've had beans and beans and cheese on a potato and it's good, it's lovely, I actually really
like it, I'd recommend it, if you ever, I'll tell you what, I'll make you,
Tadius Park, my arse, whose vomit is that, come back and clean it up,
why are we, why are we puking all of a sudden, what's going on,
oh I'll make you, oh right, we've got the coaster, right, we've got the bag, we've got the bag,
give me that junior coaster, give me that junior coaster, what we looking at,
Nausea Raton is so high on the crazy caterpillar, I mean I can see why,
however the excitement's higher so, it's 9000,
I don't have enough for that, it's 9000,
wait, if I don't include scenery, does it make it cheaper,
no, I don't have the money for that, I'm getting trolled again, no,
interest is super low, what should I just go to the bank, man I hate the bank,
gas and park, how did it go down, I don't know,
alone,
what,
did we say fuck it in my bowl,
right, junior coaster,
it takes up the whole park,
who, I can't,
I can't even fit it,
I would have to move the merry go round, okay, see you you e-bam,
how do I get rid of you, I build those the fuck out of you, clear that shit, can I sell it,
bin it, demolish, can't remove this, construction not possible while the game is paused,
okay, the people on the ride just gone forever, they'll never be seen again by their loved ones,
oh, I'm sure these people, yeah I'm pretty sure they could like walk back to where they're supposed
to go, right, you guys aren't like dumb enough that you can't see the big massive roller,
get off the tail, get off the tail, thank you, Jesus, we're playing musical tails over here,
what the, what are you doing, right, now we get the big FU one, okay, oh, sorry, I got a big say
there, that is so big, okay, okay pause, okay, okay, next, next, next, next, open,
first take the motherfucking price up, then open, and then profit surely, oh my god,
look at them like ants, wait, why does no one want to go on the ride, is it too daunting,
look at these ants, wait, everyone's too scared of it, are you too scared, I need to go to the
toilet, oh, oh, okay, I guess, right, if you need to go to the toilet, right, everyone puke right
there, and everyone get a fizzy juice, open that up, open that up, and then we're gonna put down
the benches, so no one puke, everyone sit down, and then we'll put the trash can, and then everyone's
gonna sit down, do you understand, sit down, do not puke all over my park, right okay, we're making
four dollars, do you still think it's good value, the crazy caterpillar is good value, oh yeah, that's
it, what about now, I want to go on something more thrilling than squeaky cycles, then guess what,
don't, smile, you want more exciting, what do you think of it, recent thought,
oh, you know, I've been queuing for our ages, well, I don't know what to tell you, it's really
good value, is it, thank you, thank you for your honest thoughts and opinions, why yes, of course,
what are you, I'm not hungry, this park is clean and tidy, Big Dipper looks too intense, okay, so
you're not really bothered, that's fine, I already got the umbrella and a map, why would you buy an
umbrella if the day is clear, when the day is clear, I swear, go to the bathroom, you just walked
past one, do not puke on, oh, stop it, I feel sick, I'm not, I'm not paying that much to use the
toilets, this park's really clean and tidy, so because of your refusal to pay the price, you've
just muddied up my park and then complimented it on how clean it is, disgusting, Big Dipper was
great, it was really good value, oh yeah, was it, was it good value, okay, how about that,
peak telling me your thoughts, I am tired, we built a puke shed for you right there,
it is a puke shed, that's such a good way to describe it, free bathrooms are easy ratings though,
are they, but they're making me so much profit,
what about you, is anyone, wait, everyone thinks that dollars too much, how dare you,
fine, I'll lower it to 50 cents, at least give me something for the bathrooms, don't puke,
hunger, oh my god, you're starving, I'm starving my park, yes, I'm so sorry, here, here's a chip,
right, everyone eat, yeah, eat right before the puke puddle, I'm sure it's really appetizing,
those fees pay to keep the park clean, ungrateful, literally, what are they playing at, I'm supposed
to have like 800 guests, I'm, I'm getting nervous, okay, guests in park, I think the objective is like
to have at least 750 guests in your park at the end of October on the second year,
right, my park ratings fine, but I assume you get more guests by having like more attractions,
that just need to buy, that just need to go all out on loans, well maybe if they stopped
puke and they wouldn't be so hungry, literally, why aren't they thinking of, don't be selfish,
what are you, okay, you're hungry, but it's going down, so you're fine, just eat, are you squidding
me right now, Tim's too damn, I mean, if you want to get technical, Amy's done
that, oh advertising, why yes, of loan interest, on flu, company value, park values,
so what, okay, I can't take that down, vouchers for free drink, why not, go,
369 guests, I can't believe it, they knew what was going on, right, what are we feeling now,
what's our body, I'm not paying that much to use toilet for, well they all cost the same,
so shut up and go for a job, toilet, you're gonna shit yourself, instead of pay five cents,
how about ten cents, you cheap bastard, you want to get off the big wheel, well good thing you're
not on it, no, no, no, we are not getting on this ride just to puke, you are not going past the
bathrooms, I feel sick, this path is disgusting, use the trash can, yes, right, sit down, stay seated,
stay seated, do I make myself clear, stay seated, do not move, crazy caterpillar, star,
why does that get a star, what, you're gonna puke but you love the ride, I feel very sick, I need
to go to the toilet, I feel sick, okay, you just, a bumbly boot, why would you buy an umbrella,
I guess a star means, you can always drown them, don't forget,
then I'll get done for killing, wait, who destroyed the freaking benches, hello, hello,
benches can be destroyed, am I going crazy, I've never seen that before, do I need to like
breathe make benches, is that security, you have no security, there's hooligans running a muck in my
park, you better sort them out, right now, that's right, five nights at Freddy's, is this where you
want to be, I'm just gonna get it, why do you want to stay five nights at Freddy's,
Scottish version cover when, right now baby,
oh
nice to meet you, ohayou gozaimasu,
what is this, from Viola Gen 1,
I ain't gonna know Japanese and me, I'm Scottish, be nice, okay, what version is this, this is the
deluxe version because it was gonna break, which is in Japanese, yeah, I am Japanese,
the best you're getting is a Hatsune Miku song from me, I'm so sorry, I'm thinking Miku,
Miku, health violation, restrooms deserve to be three, okay, and then why, what's going on with
my, oh I can just push the cursor to the edge of the screen to move the thing, right, in, in
memorial of Inspector Craig's son or Craig, I don't know how you say it, it's either Craig or Craig,
the toilets are now free, in the name of your son, I've been queuing for cycles for ages, what,
am I supposed to tell them to hurry up, what, what do you want, can I tell them to hurry up,
maximum wait time, what does that mean, wait for a full load,
wait for any load, just send them, what do you mean a full load, just freaking send them,
um, oh so you know Japanese, why yes of course I do,
stop, that's not funny, too many guests, not enough rides, okay, okay, I hear you, I hear you,
I hear you, oh I'm at my max lend amount,
tell me, thank you Broly Living, Lollipop, Stroney would have been too powerful,
no she's gonna go, we need a water ride, okay, let's, let's analyze, I don't, I don't actually
think they've been, yeah it's making me, I need like pre-made stuff or it's not happening,
your marketing campaign for free drinks, but it did push up to 425 guests, I tell you what,
this is a very low energy ride, but we will make a profit on it, okay,
so entrance, exit,
and then we need the queuing one for the entrance, right, yes, oh my gosh, oh my, oh yeah Mr. Krabs
and then every, no not that one, draft, okay, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on,
all right, all right, all right, all right, all right, my baby don't mess around,
nope, just, just send them in, send them in, I couldn't hear,
and then number of rotations, that's fine, full load, any, I don't know, maybe a full load,
I don't know, I don't know, I'm just, I mean, sounds like it's time for scrambled eggs one to appear,
wait is that real, is that an actual ride's name though, there's a ferris wheel, no we already
have one, marigold round, canoes round boats, custom design layout, custom, custom, custom, a canny,
design, car ride, powered vehicle, road works, I sure hope it does, thank you, I'm sorry,
right, okay, we're gonna get one of those, give me a loan, thank you, okay, what was that just
looking at, was that a car ride, I was just looking at something,
one design available, wait, oh it's 5k, I can't afford it,
where is that thing I just looked at, miniature reel, wait, monorail,
no, I've already got one of them, don't give me them, what, wait, I'm actually blind, it can't be
monorail, custom design layout, miniature reel way, what, what was I just looking at, monorail,
you are literally the embodiment of brain rot of the last 10 years, thank you,
I've never been more complimented on my life, you can even change the operation of some small
ride to have multiple of them, the queue is longer than the ride reel,
second row first column, car ride, right, no, I, right, let me,
excitement is both the same, intensity, sure, let's do this one,
is this face in the wrong way,
okay, wait, if it's, is this face in the wrong way, I think I'm, yeah,
that wasn't it,
I guess we'll do it like here, how do I connect this,
where do you touch the floor,
am I gonna have to build a ramp like a big girl, oh no, oh no, what have I done,
oh wait, it's there, honestly, right, first we need, right, okay,
so this is what, the waiting area, okay, so there's already a waiting area, that's the good news, build,
okay, hold on, hold on, let me, okay, we just need to do a little bit, but okay,
can you connect these two, okay, you're not quite getting it, you're not quite getting it,
but that's okay, we're gonna get there, you can't remove this, construction's not possible, we'll
pause, well, we just need to figure out a path, and surely this isn't going to be difficult,
okay, build a bridge, okay, jungle racers, that's the only way to be called that,
what do I need to do, how do, hi, we're just currently trying to figure out how to do passing
in this game, no, no, but other way, like that way, yes,
confirm, no, okay, build it, okay, I mean, okay, okay, okay, go along, along, along,
oh, all right, okay, okay, and then rotate, okay, and then we're gonna go this way,
okay, and then we're gonna connect it to the path, oh, we did it, oh my god, that took a little bit
too much IQ, I'm gonna be honest, let's get you up to like four dollars, since I have to take
like an insane loan out on you, go, I don't need the safety checks, I just need you to go, okay,
and then we will put loads of benches, so everyone will sit down,
everyone will sit down, do I make myself clear, he will sit down,
he will sit down, everyone sit down and puke into the trash cans,
pervaded on your walk back from the raid,
let's just put some benches around for the people that need a little seat,
because you can't expect people to like walk the entire length of the park,
so that ferris wheel is bumping, god damn, we need a second one, right, we have now have a new raid,
the alun, oh, there's flowers, okay, water thoughts, people, water thoughts, recent thoughts,
nothing, honestly me, real, true, oh no, my rollercoaster, autism has been enabled,
why are you going on so many raids, raids,
okay, what are you guys doing, tell me your thoughts, I want to go on something more thrilling,
I'm no thirsty though, right, that's good, do I need to put, no, because there's like literally
food access right there, do I need to put a shitter off here, I don't know, maybe,
when the music stops and gaming is really creepy, you're just,
you're in a room with me and nothing else, you don't need music,
actually I just don't hear any of the music,
I hear a bit of something,
I hear a bit, you've been invited to Inspector Craig's funeral,
wait, no, what, why did he die, I have a mechanic,
I have a mechanic, how did he die, boy, I had a heart attack,
Inspector Craig's sore, sore, we had a heart attack,
a rip craig, it's either Craig or Craig, it's Craig in the Scots mostly,
F in the chats for Craig, rip craig, it was nice knowing your buddy,
okay, let's see what you guys are saying, I'm not hungry, I've already got a park map,
this park is good value, I want to go on something more, oh the maps are good value,
thank you, thank you very much, I'll be here all day,
imagine throwing up on a rollercoaster, the amount of days,
I've seen those horrible videos of someone vomiting and like the other people just accept
their fate because there's nothing you can do, you're strapped in for the next minute,
I'm not hungry, are you actually not hungry or are you just saying that,
oh no you're not, everything, oh you're happiness, you're not exactly ecstatic though,
not exactly ecstatic are you, well you are but you're thirsty, right, let's
assume you're gonna go over, is everyone thirsty in this general area though,
oh they are, okay, I guess we'll get another drink thing, even though the drink thing is like
oh, can, will it, off the map, oh it does, same price there at the park, yeah, where is that
can I not charge more than,
nah it's just that word, how are you guys looking, you're not that happy,
what am I so miserable for, he put a star on, assume it if the star, it means it made the
guest ecstatic basically, right no one's vomiting, oh but he's hungry, okay, if you're too daft to
walk past the, like walk past all the, right fine, we'll just put toilets up here as well,
oh right, we'll put a toilet up here because everyone's gonna be pooping and pant alone and
right there, boom, you have everything you could possibly need right here
and the toilets are free, you're welcome, at the expense of, at the expense of our, our overlord
shareholders, the toilets are free
is this roller coaster stall even making that much money, I even know where the entrance is, you know that
oh it's over here, okay, let me, let me just do a little cheeky rotation
make it six dollars for a war ball to add to the realism, well remember this is the, wait
wait, it has a datatur,
the man who made this, his autism was on fire, literally what, it has a freaking
velocity altitude vertical Gs,
this man knew what he wanted,
he absolutely kicked, no wonder roller coaster type thing went far,
sorry but look at this, it's literally got a heart rate monitor,
it's literally got a heart rate monitor, that's insanity,
look, the power of autism anything possible, look at that, boom, and he just, oh they flatlined,
oh, oh I'm sorry, right, I mean who wouldn't want to know the terminal velocity of each ride,
sure, wasn't there another amusement park singing, the one I played and just tortured people,
refunds are you okay, did I need to call someone, I mean trouble, right, we unlocked something,
what was it, custom, custom, custom, custom, and then it went, it says this is 5K,
oh,
oh, I mean we could get it without any customization, but I feel like that's what people get excited
about, the scenery, I don't know, what was that steel thing,
steel chaperone, oh, ponytails, okay, is this too big for me, oh no, sorry I didn't need to build
custom, I just wanted to see how big it was, oh we can actually fit it, okay, where's the entrance
here, yes, not enough cash, that's okay, okay, but we can't afford it, that's the good news,
we're not allowed to have any more kind of money, you know, if you named the ride after
yourself, we would all say we wrote Strongly True, I'll do it with an X and have that,
I'll change the name to Strongly Broke Down, and before Strongly Broke Down, send maintenance,
will you play Zutai-kun, the Nintendo DS game, absolutely, I'm obsessed with it, I will force
you guys to do the whole campaign mode with me, I love Zutai-kun, and once it's set up,
you don't even have to do anything, like all the money just goes flying in,
I love me some Zutai-kun, right, well how much, we need 5K for the next steel thing, I feel sick,
so sit down, stop puking everywhere, only have two genres,
stop puking right in front of the third stalls, pick anywhere else, go up over path and pick
anywhere else, sitting down after puking all over yourself, get out of here, sit down,
everyone sit down, God you're like babies,
I believe I have to even do this, how are you guys looking, are you looking awful,
trying to like put it on the footpath but I'm not sure, it's not, okay, okay I see it,
all right one more here as well, just for good luck,
Sony is really good value, Sony looks too intense for me,
stop that's so good, I'll definitely be reading your mind, right what are you,
the jungle racer with great right, but do you want to say it's good value or,
are you gonna tell me, I'm not hungry or thirsty, no you're not, you're just walking past
literally the hunger and thirst, what are you doing, I'm like caterpillar was great,
hungry thirsty, you need the toilets, you're fine, I need a few more benches, I think I might
actually need a few more benches, I don't want to make people walk for a long time because I'm
like oh I get tired too, I'm so exhausted, stop puking at the front of my freaking thing,
park is it that hard, Sony is too tame, invest in Sony, I've got 3000 right now,
we've got one, let's see what was it, it was a steel coaster, it was a steeple chase,
Raiders horse ride shaped vehicles which run along a singular track and it's 40,
4662, okay we're gonna stick it like somewhere here, I'm gonna have like a connection like
somewhere here and then if we want to expand we can maybe do boring stuff up this way,
me when I walk 0.1 centimetre, honestly what have I started, you can open a list of other
recent thoughts, okay we will do that one, give me $400 please, with a cherry on top,
please, please, okay hydration check refunds, you need to make sure you're hydrating,
I need to look after you, I need to make sure you,
how's the tiger going, I'm becoming the very thing I swore to destroy
and I love it, I love when numbers go up in video game, it's so easy in video game,
okay, almost there, 100 more dollars and then we can buy the scrawny ride,
400, want to show some melons too, actually I'll link you that, please remind me at the end of
the stream to link you guys to the Emmy clip, if you didn't know Emmy got clip,
when and she showed her fondle of cleavage,
well looking at your 16.1k so it's also easy for you,
bro I already have the thigh thing, fondle in her bosom, the lego clip, yeah the lego clip,
by the way she's scrawny, no stinger, no I've no transfer to stingers, hold on let me,
I'll write it in my notes, right, stingers, tomorrow please, the reeflings
are begging, don't forget you bi cth, okay I'll try, okay we need 100 more dollars then we can
pay for this ride, it was so good, the valleys were very valley, I just watched it before stream,
I love smoothies flips, legend, hey you can't call my wife that word, little sister challenged
shout and found out, literally, big bros, big bros are like, bet, unironically separate real
sibling relationship because they're like I bet, right where's the entrance, the entrance is like,
oh god this is really awkward,
isn't that gonna destroy the bridge,
this, or is it, no, hmm,
maybe it'd be better if it was actually over here,
is there a room,
she keeps on under us to be in us, real,
is there a room, hold on sorry, I need to check if this is skinny enough, I'm gonna see,
what, wait sorry I'm trying to, I need to think of where the entrance is gonna go,
I think that's the best I can do, all things considered, right pause first and then we can
deal with whatever terrible mapping we need to do,
I actually can't even tell what I'm looking at, I said it's closed, right so I need to
connect these two platforms, okay we have an objective, we have an objective, right a bridge,
shit, don't do that, don't do that again, okay,
nope, nice try but, pull again, what,
what,
no, this one, yeah well that'll do, that'll do, I mean, no stop doing that pathway,
isn't that the waiting pathway,
oh, we have to go up, oh man we gotta go bold,
wait go back one, yeah do that, wait hold on, go and then go up,
yeah no you're supposed to connect to the pathway, oh man, oh man,
go that, right, I mean is it still like that, hold on, let me, let me just, let me just,
why is this, right click to remove, no,
yes, okay, but don't give me that path, give me this path and then go up and then go flat,
oh my god, right okay, okay but hold on, hold on, let me get up, let me get up,
I just need to fix this one over here because that's wrong and then,
okay, okay, okay, okay that, we did it, we did it, we have a new ride, we have a new ride,
it just took us a hot second but we did it, that's the main thing right, let's hike the price up as
we always do and then open it, no we don't need to test it, I have full faith that everything
will go fine, smile and then play and then hopefully that spreads out more guests
and then things won't be so overwhelming for like the other rides as well,
let's just put the trash can here, let's put loads of benches because we're starting to expand
that thing, what is the ride, I need to call it strong, where do I lean in at, oh it's all green as well
hey there we go, you guys ready to ride this one,
oh my god it actually changes the thing here, you can raid me, we did it after two hours,
you can raid me, we did it, we did it, it only took me two hours, that was a lot of work to
get there but we did it, where's the lane, new attraction, a burger bar, so now we offer burger
yeah just put on top of the ride that thing, is the game trolling right now,
I thought it was like all adjusted to the pathway but I guess not, sure why not shove a burger joint
like right there, we'll take up the craze as always do, okay we have 500 guests, what is our
timeline, I think we're almost there, guests in park 500 right and it keeps going off every month
so we're doing fine, I just don't know about the free attraction, that's okay,
have at least 750 by October year two, we're not even in year two, wait are we going to be
hanging about waiting for this map to finish, that's right make me money, why yes of course
everyone makes me money, look at all those green things, I've become the big differ broke down,
I hope I have an account, I do, okay he's been called in, okay September, we're in September right
we're definitely gonna be moving faster, I don't even know if we have him, we rode you in the last
audio, don't get greedy real, I do too, the big differ's still broken after years, wait where is
he, what are you doing, what is the big differ anyway, that's the caterpillar,
oh that's the big differ, where is he, is he just like not in the park, go to your fucking door
he was glitched out that time, is that what this is, if they're not like on the ground
okay the park's definitely losing the cleanliness awardee, joking with all the vomit
but we still don't have all the guests though, okay hold on, what's the cheapest raid we have,
probably what the big differ, sure let's just do everything,
advertise campaign of the park, go for it, just send them all in okay, for a particular raid,
do the scrawny, advertise scrawny, go go go go, let's get like 750 guests in here, okay and then
we're gonna zoom, we're zooming, we're zooming, security guard is walking, he's walking, I think
we're gonna have to buy more janners, so the guests are at 300 though, hey sorry 650 guests,
he's going up, I believe in you, Mary go around can never go wrong, oh we've unlocked dojooms, okay
dojooms, what are dojooms, are they a wee raid, gentle raid, no dojooms you're getting bashed
about, it can't be a gentle raid, which perhaps this is, perhaps the dojooms are the ones we made
along the way, D for dojooms, oh found them, what, oh my god yes, um where do we fit it,
oh we can fit it over here really easily, let's do that, there's Rick
where is the entrance, I really, okay that my only thing was be, I wish you could pause to like
catch off a little bit, yeah entrance, you made the entrance, okay there we go
and then exit here and then guests are complaining about the disgusting state of your park,
check where your handyman are, okay well give me a second I'm trying to expand, I can't do this
all at once, stop this madden, yeah do it like that so we actually have some time in case it gets
really popular please, do that and then we can open dojooms but first we must take the price up,
open, okay okay we did it right, disgusting state of park, okay let's get a few more of you around,
uh who's disgusting, who's causing the disgust, is it this right over here, be honest,
where's the puke, this is just puke finder simulator, where are you guys puking over here be honest,
no, oh there's a janitor that's maybe just, oh my game just crashed there, oh here it is, okay how
about you go I don't know and no do not do gardening I will cry, handyman, okay cleaning up,
cleaning up, why are we puking over here, what's going on, why is there litter, I have, I have
fine well hire another one, hey you guys are, you suck, I do so much for you, this is why the
shareholders are so fucked, we worked so hard, right bins, clearly we need more bins, I don't know
how but sure more bins, more benches, your marketing campaign has ended, disgusting litter bugs everywhere,
there's literally a bin there, where inspector create, he passed away unfortunately, I think I
might buy the lord, your advertising campaign for scrawny has finished, whoa this is bad, I've
been queuing for scrawny for ages, right well she's trying her best, damn she can't fucking serve
everyone at once, it's a single, it's a single use rate for a reason, single one at a time rate for
a reason, not single use, that's not how any of that works, one at a time for a reason, be nice,
right I think what we'll do is we'll invest in the lower excitement things because I think
they'll increase the overall like people in the park, unless I'm just making that up but I feel like
I don't think I can fit a water, I don't think I could fit though,
no there's no way I can fit it, that's okay though, I tried,
and I'm not demolishing that roller coaster, keep investing on scrawny, real true,
I'll know if you keep investing in everyone else and deal with you,
alright I can't, I can only really do the wee rides now,
right we'll put down the wee rides because I think it will increase overall park attendees,
you know, and it's just like a small thing that doesn't really,
it doesn't exactly cost like a lot to have or anything like that so I'm quite,
because I just hear someone hear, I might have, it's very possible, right build a wee thing,
okay and then turn it on,
but first take the price off, I did it the wrong way but fine, just take it off a little bit,
get new attraction open, go go go, thank you Broly legend for the super jet,
crazy glitches, you sound to me, time to make a custom coaster,
I can't bring myself to do it, I can't, I'm too scared, stop this madness please,
what do you want from me, what is another born ride, a gentle ride, a merry go round,
do they have one, dodgums, strawnee, whatever that was, a little spinny thing,
god that one is making some fat, like I can see all them little pixels moving, I don't remember you
but we've got a ferris wheel round, a merry go round, okay I've got a merry go round and a ferris,
I've got a ferris wheel, not a merry go round, oh my gosh, a huge respect for your most recent
twitter short, did you enjoy it, I like showing the behind the scenes, I don't mind it, I've got a
few questions I'm probably gonna develop, someone was like how much is that in like youtube premium
and I was like well because I do ASMR my youtube premium is a bit not this, can you move over a
bit, my youtube premium will be different from others because I do ASMR specifically and yeah,
I don't talk about the behind the scenes but I don't know if people are like you're fucking
I don't really want to put anything like
just like put onto, that is ridiculous, can I just do that, that's silly, don't be so silly,
you're making me giggle, you're making me have a giggle, the silliness, twisters broken down
that's it, let's put that off a wee bit, it's just a nice calm gentle raid and then overall
hopefully it'll help have more people at least give me a bit of a chance to open it up please
before you all start paling in, right so that's two relaxing raids across from each other
and literally it's up to people, whoever what they want to go on that's fine, doesn't stop me,
doesn't stop them, thank you all for your voice because it's super chat but I'm
glad you like it, the park is designed to test your space management, well it's
bloody working, I'm already ran out of space, I probably should have shoved this like way in
the back corner possibly, I don't know maybe we can get like some sort of skinny roller coaster
next, I don't know what the game is investing in, it's just investing in everything
right, scenery and theming, no, shops and stalls, no, water rides, transport rides,
I enjoyed it very much, was a very brave piece of content, your transparency and business savvy
is inspiring, um people were surprised and I'm like she you thought I wasn't going to be a success
that sounds so arrogant please please I'm actually cringing at that, what I meant to say was
I didn't have doubts, I wouldn't have invested if I had any doubt about like anything I wouldn't
have invested, simple as like there was failure is not an option, it literally, it cannot happen
and I mean it didn't so, thank you again for the uh super chat of the voice, I call you
Otter voice a second ago, I think I did sorry for the tea, dim posters crushed, is there no ride
improvement research, um I guess not, I never saw anything like that, um it just says, who goes
transport, gentle roller and thrill, I'm how much, research has taken 200, marketing is 200,
staff wages 1.3, food and drink, I'm not making a profit on food and drink,
oh to stock it, but sales are top, ticket rides are off, landscaping,
no, no worries people are always under, it's not happy, eight of time belch, your dedication is
abnormal, oh thank you, you're not, it's not the arrogant, you're confident, it's a good thing,
then but also I'm making strongly the best, a failure isn't an option, how am I here, you're
not a failure, don't talk about yourself like that you silly goober, if you say stuff like I'm
right hold on a minute, hold on I'm gonna put my tin foil hat on because it's not even a tin foil
foil hat, if you talk to yourself like that you will start believing in your, you'll start to
believe it okay, so you know how it's like fake it until you make it, if you're nasty to yourself
you're not gonna have a good time, you need to be nice to yourself, I'm actually being serious as
well, like you have to say to yourself like I can like it's called positive affirmation, please
do not puke, sit down, oh my god sit down, don't puke, I know it's called positive affirmations,
either you believe it or you don't, but I'm not being funny, if you're poisoning yourself with
the same poison every single day, you're gonna be poisoned you know, but if you
do meme about and you know, say like oh you know what actually I'm a bit of a decent person or
like I do try my best, just because like you've done bad shit in the past, it doesn't mean you're
unredeemable or some shit, like what the fuck, literally every, think of every video game you've
ever, right get that price of the umbrellas up right now, hold on a minute, hold on a minute,
and wait why do I have two kiosks right next to each other, same price, same price, get them
umbrellas up, 350s, unethical, but true, you were most likely taught to hate yourself along the
way, literally think of high school, there's this thing called like, I think it's like the
blooming flower theory or something like that, and it's like if you dare to be slightly different
then the status quo, you get picked on, you get bullied, you get this, you get that,
no more, no more, literally no more, like I get to be my weird self, you guys accept me,
and I hope I extend that love and that belonging towards you, of like yeah you've got brain worms,
okay, I'm not gonna hate you for it, that's just how it is, so let's see what we can do,
let's have fun, you know, let's give each other purpose if we can, or a sense of community,
a sense of belonging, because like, you know, you're really harsh to yourself, I wish you weren't
as harsh to yourself, and maybe over time I can teach you, you know, to be nicer, kinder to
yourself, I really like the neon color difference in the puke, that's really nice, I like the neon
shade too, preach it strongly, took me years to learn, is that my eyeball, oh it is my eyeball,
it's not my eyeball, you take my eye, honestly I go through the phrase, don't be sorry, be better,
don't ask for permission, ask for forgiveness, real, real, me when I come online and I'm like,
the girls said what, how do you know about my brain worms, who told you, everyone has brain
worms, hell even I have brain worms, but I don't know, because I've just been allowed to do my thing
and be myself and just meme about, I don't really get, I'm like, I don't, I've said this before,
I don't experience like, imposter syndrome, I don't really have any of that, I don't know,
it's kind of hard to, I don't mean to, what's the word, sympathize and empathize, sympathize is
when you haven't had it yourself, it's not that it's hard to sympathize, because I just, I'm just like,
so obviously I've just kind of preached about being nice to yourself, but because I know my
limitations when it comes to content, I will never produce anything that's 100 out of 100,
you know what I mean, like I'll never get a score like that, so what's the point of like holding
myself up to that, like I mean, fuck, I'm literally on a game that is what, two decades old, I couldn't
even learn how to do the paths at the start, am I gonna say it myself, oh, oh, I should have done
this, I should have done that, no, I'm gonna giggle at myself and be like, haha, I didn't even know
how to do paths at the start of this game, like, you know, you will judge yourself more harshly
than anyone could ever look upon you, okay, and keep that in your mind, because it will, it could
swoop in and save you from just spiraling, you will only judge yourself as harsh, I mean, what's
that Emmy mean, where it's literally like, you're too afraid to be perceived that you cannot enjoy
life, like, or something, yeah, you're too afraid to be perceived by others, that you can't enjoy
your life, and it's like, come on, you only have one chance, oh my god, they're all puking into the
bucket, it's working, like, enjoy what you enjoy, sorry, but everyone puking into the bucket,
buckets for everyone, everyone puked, I didn't realize they actually picked up the bin and puked
in it, I love it here, stream can't be lower than 10 of the person's streamers attempt, how dare you,
and get kissed, get loved on, how dare you, sympathizing is feeling bad for someone else,
is mis- empathizing, put yourself in, I thought you could only do empathy if you had gone through
it yourself, oops, what's that, my English, my terrible English is coming back to haunt me,
and also, hey, I was lurking but broke it because you've got points, still suffering from
in real life responsibilities, so honestly, it's really good to see you in front of your hand,
you'll be a busy bee, yeah, a busy bee, yeah, let it be nicer to yourself, and you can only,
only you can practice it, now you may be listening, you're like, yeah, yeah, strong, you're, you're,
you're, you're a strong slash, and that's true, just maybe be a bit nicer and just be like, oh,
you know what, maybe I will have a good day, smile, maybe I will enjoy myself today,
smile, where are you, what are you doing, oh, he's got a drink in his hand, you better not let her,
later bug, oh no, that's not what this song, it just occurred to me that the song that goes,
wait, is this song, let her bug, no, it can't be, let her bug,
you gotta go, boom, boom, into my heart, I do want you, guys be nice,
Englishes are setting language, Scots are the first, real and true, thank you British government for
recognizing that Scottish slang is a different lingo, I will read you guys a book, that's actually
Scottish slang, you know, love it, you guys will be like, what did I just read, and I'll be like,
hehehe, you're going to educate me, believe in yourself, and don't deny happiness to yourself,
find happiness wherever you can, love and happiness can be found in the smallest of places,
hold on a minute, I'm pulling up the quote, I'm pulling up the quote,
I'm pulling up the quote, I'm pulling it up, I can't remember off the top of my head,
okay, you ready for this, okay, the quote is coming,
and check her bug, you put the boom, boom, into my heart, wake me up,
instead of great positivity or great negativity, I have great and different, hey look,
sometimes it's better to just be like, yep, this is life, than to be like, oh shoot, this is life,
you know, you know what I'm saying, right, time for the quote, some believe it is only great power
that can hold evil and check, but that, hold on a minute, it's on the wrong screen,
but that is not what I have found, it is the small everyday deeds of ordinary folk that
keep the darkness at bay, small acts of kindness and life, that's the quote, I want you to remember
that, and no, I know Saruman isn't coming to killers or something like evil like that, I know,
but I think there's a lot of truth to it, it is the small everyday deeds of ordinary folk,
like me and you little reefling, okay, have you killed anyone yet, no, I'm trying to be wholesome
right now, are you serious, yeah, what Anonymous, what are you saying to us, Saruman, the stinky,
please, I love that meme so much, Anonymous, what are you saying to us, you say, hi strongy,
I'm honestly kind of jealous of you and the rest of you, I've always wanted to entertain others
and you six have found the courage to step up and do what I've wanted to do since I was a kid,
maybe I'll shake off the rust and get back to my roots, I heavily encourage you to do so,
when I say the term, you only live once, what I don't want, why the fuck is there a banana on
the top of the chip shop, oh it's a chip, sorry, bit distracted, when I say you only live once,
what I don't mean behind that sentence is, oh my god, you must achieve absolutely everything
you possibly could have ever wanted to do in this lifetime, no, what I mean by you only live once is
give it a shot, give it a shot, I don't know if you've heard the theory that 80% of the work
is done by showing up and doing it and going for it, but that is very true and very real,
I say go for it because what's the harm, oh no, right so what's the downside of giving
giving it a shot, oh I might not find success, okay but what's the good things, you got to
explore a hobby that you're passionate about, you got to expand upon your creativity of you
yourself that I've done, another benefit, you might find success, so if you're trying
to sell me on the down points of not pursuing your hobby, you're preaching to the wrong choir
because this choir over here is singing like something else, I don't know what song we're singing,
okay I'm just a memer, that's what song we're singing and I'm just a memer,
you know, it operates on the same logic, if you write down your problem, you're halfway through
solving them, yeah that kind of stuff, okay, you only get one shot, shoot, shoot the whoop, oh yeah,
yeah, banana, it's a banana, please tell me that looks like a banana, not a chip,
you miss every shot you don't take, my friend who misses archery, 50% of it, for real, if you're
so worried just to dress up, makes you think it'll fall off and then go for it, literally send it,
send it, send it, people wearing it, reflins are wearing it, like you spent 60,000 US dollars
to starve an agency, do you think I was sitting like stressed and over, send it,
send it, just go for it, don't hold yourself back, don't be the reason you hold yourself back,
darling, go for it, well to be fair you were very stressed out, oh well now I'm not stressed
out anymore because the girls are doing their thing, right, we're gonna zoom ahead because I
would've achieved what we need to achieve, oh my god, look at all that sea of green, oh, a wooden
wail-the-mouse, get me on that, what is it, new raid attraction, wooden wail-the-mouse,
a wooden wail-so you're saying I have a shop in my-clam, yeah,
you didn't hear that, you didn't, for a legal reason, what, excitement right into the castello
is insane, hello, oh my god we can fit it, oh my god we feel like you're gonna fit,
no, you're gonna slot right in right there, yeah, you're gonna slot right in for me,
why is it not,
oh, that's the entrance there,
oh, let's do the path here, oh I didn't need to do that, but we did it,
okay, and then then we need to open the raid, but first take the price up,
who goes there, five dollars, I know it's a lot but the excitement is like insane on this ride,
I'm not even kidding, I can't text, all I hear is strawberries just screaming,
the house is right behind, well hey you will look fun, oh my, I never even thought about that to be
considerate, could you imagine every day all you hear is,
do not invade anyone, did you hear the big Scottish drama, I'm about to clue you in the
Scotland drama, so you know how there's Nessie, the Loch Ness monster, right, so she is like moaning
or screaming at me, so Loch Lomond is where Nessie lives, right, the aquatic, whatever you want to
call her, and basically why are none of you going on the ride, okay, I've spent how much on that ride
and none of you are going for it, and the drama is someone is trying to purchase Loch Lomond to
open up a theme park on it, and everyone's like, it's literally a conservation area for, not reservation,
sorry, a conservation for nature area thing, you know what I mean, that's what you're gonna,
that's what your neighbours are gonna hear, no that's what the convention staff are gonna hear, amen,
can I get an amen, stop, stop, right Broly legend, thank you for this super chat,
um so since you're a cutlery, so you get along with Nessie, obviously we're both aquatic and we
love you, basically it was Johnny with her legs at the war, oh my god you've got me, you've got me, amen,
what is, um okay can I tell you one of the dumbest streams I wanted to do,
but I don't think I can, so I have been watching black churches on TV right, and it's so fun and
energetic and I love it, and they all have a keyboard in the background, okay, so I wanted to do a
confession stream, but it was like we were singing Jesus songs as well, that was going to be the
stream idea, but I don't know if that's really dumb and I shouldn't speak ever again, god everyone
is lining up for this new, where are you all, you're all hiding like moments ago, I'm probably
gonna need to add more toilets now I think, I would definitely add a shitter, okay there we go,
we've got a shitter, open it up, a wreath stream, a wreath slay, that and oh and oh and oh, wait
what's the name, August, confession stream sex on unspronied, do it you only live one, well
literally like I was gonna get you guys to confess and then we'd all have a giggle over it, a little
giggle, and then I was gonna like sing a song in between it, like I know that sounds so silly,
but like I thought that was the best idea ever and I was like wait a minute, someone gonna be
weird and be like oh you're making fun of this and I'm like no motherfucker, you're order, right
that's a drink, so now we'll do an ice cream, ice cream for ice cream, an ice cream for your...
I'm gonna be honest, if you heard me verbally smack my mouth, it's because I'm not paying attention
to what I'm saying and it just comes out, okay it just comes out, it just comes out,
I literally, I'm just bichining, and my brain just goes for it, she's putting the ice cream
next to the toilet, oh my god do you guys remember two girls one cup,
and then the big debate was like it's ice cream,
I remember the debate was like ice cream, why must you remind me, no, wasn't that, wait were you
guys not like the debate of it, it was literally like okay I'm gonna have to hire another mechanic,
okay answering a radio call, okay I think we maybe need a second mechanic, I don't know how to
see it but wait what broke down, who or what isn't moving, we're not, I don't know,
and I'll just let him do the rounds, ice cream argument was just copied on, oh was it,
what debate, it was ice cream, the company that made it admitted to it, oh
I've never seen the argument and now that I'm picturing it I don't want to, I'm sorry,
I don't remember the debate but I remember that, cease okay right I'll stop, I'll stop, I'll stop,
right we've almost finished the park, I am gonna update Azura and mine Patreon when I get off,
I know I said I was gonna do it yesterday, I'm so sorry, I'm behind everywhere but the girls
are being so patient and fantastic with me so please don't worry,
I just read that comment in chat, I shouldn't have started, anyway, oh look how many reeflings
want to ride strong, let's go, 86 of you are lining, 87 are lining up right now to raid me
and you're paying me, can I add more cars, if I add more cars, is someone, oh there's only five
talk about exclusivity, that's that big train, guys she's behind me,
but why is everyone digging this ferris wheel, is it because it has a view, what's the music for
the ferris wheel, modern, I can hear hints of something, one coaster for each girl when,
honestly my mind is here, really squeaky, reliability down time 6%, that's fine,
minimum wait time so far, rock, no rock doesn't make sense for such a gentle thing,
let's not do that, what are you thinking, recent thoughts, no thoughts, real, true,
queuing for strone, right, how do I read action thoughts, I feel sick, I'm running out of cash,
I'm not hungry, I feel sick, I've been queuing for strone, this path is disgusting,
this park is really clean and tidy, so we've got a few contradicting things, that's like a stop us,
can't stop us with our order, okay you guys are actually using the bin, a Christmas miracle,
truly a Christmas miracle, right I think we're gonna need a lot more seats for how many people
we have, maybe a few more in the pathway and stuff, I don't want people to be like exhausted,
are you squinting me right now, what, in the vomit park, straight up rioting it,
and by it, haha well, let's just say, strone, thank you for the tip and honest, actually that
just reminded me, in my most recent short, Arisa has like full control of the shorts that she makes
for me, if you pause my most recent short, it literally, she put that copy pasta in it,
because she's heard me say it, and I'm like Arisa, but it was so funny, it's just that and by it,
I mean my pimpus, like Arisa, I wasn't gonna see that for the first time and be like what, wild,
okay I think it's safe to say that we have, actually we could probably pay a bit of our debt,
go, yeah okay, and then we just skip ahead, because we're done, oh look at that sea of green,
oh aren't you getting that serotonin, oh wait there's a ghost train attraction, hold on pause, pause,
ghost train, oh we've got a pirate ship, I didn't even know we had that,
what's a pirate, a what, power monster shaped cars travel 3000,
hold on give me the loan back, give me a bag, give me a bag, give me a bag, give me my money,
ghost train surely it's not going to be too big that it won't fit, surely,
I'll take it, I'll take it, I can't see, I can't see how skinny the path is, well I'll take it,
right okay first, open, next, hike up the price, buy a lot because the prices are starting to match
each other, and then the path, let's, let's add it, I can't see anything right now, I think I did it,
okay, now this ride is getting completely ignored because of its unfortunate location,
like I literally cannot see it, but we'll just do the classic bins and benches outside,
and then we're gonna rotate again, okay one person's gone up that path, oh there's a big
scary boy on top, you're queuing for it, why, the thing should be on, are they actually doing
a test run, I can't believe it, that's Mr Bone, the ride never ends, is it actually Mr Bone,
make a bank, yes I trained that ends with the wall, the ghost is after, is you after the ride,
this is a reference, like clearly do not know, right okay now we can speed it up because we've
done what the game asks, it said 750 guests and we're at 875, so I think we're okay,
Park rate in 945, not bad, it must be the vomit that's doing it, I can't believe it,
the vomit's letting us down, shocking, if everyone could kindly stop, you're a king,
I've just noticed the people that are sitting don't come out of the animation,
0 out of 10 game, unplayable, unplayable, absolutely shocking,
slide is broken down, well I have two mechanics so surely one of them's getting on it,
surely, big dipper is broken down, can everything relax please, please everything
relax you're making me cry, new rate, Cheshire cat, what is it, is it in the gentle one, no that's
a water one, Cheshire, Cheshire are you here, you are, how big are you when you're big,
Cheshire you're too big, I can't have them,
we're all mad here Alice, I can't have them, he's too big, smell,
we'll finish our lovely park and then we'll wrap up streaming on VDirect okay,
dog jumps is broken down, that's what she didn't say, that's what she said, don't say it,
wait what did I say, what did I say, her once, I wouldn't, attention, hey,
everything's breaking, oh no it's because we're doing months apart right, September, October,
so we're about to get the screen that says congrats you won surely, I've probably done something wrong
but yay, they did re-publish this game, still hasn't been fixed,
well they better hurry up, where are you going, responding to crazy cat pillar,
where are you, he's on it right, it's fine he's on it, he's on it like a car bonnet, right let's pay our
debts and then I guess we'll just go, twister is broken down, oh no I might actually need another
mechanic, I can't believe it, have you tried open rcp too, I haven't, I have no idea what that is,
you did it, I didn't know you could win at this game, oh you get like a mission objective,
just got here, I'm listening at work right now, sorry if I don't interact, no don't worry don't
how is it not being fixed, is he glitching out or something,
are Virginia real, are Virginia real, we're just going to have another mechanic down because I
don't know what is going on, all of a sudden everything's breaking down, right what is that,
look everything's breaking down, I think maybe when I speed up they're not, breakdown breakdown
breakdown, whole park's bloody shot, right what's that Virginia wheel,
what's wrong with me, a Virginia wheel sorry, the whole park is breaking down by not giving
me, don't believe her lies, Virginia is a silo, what it's not real state,
a Texas tube, oh well I like it, can I get away with it here, why not,
crazy caterpillars in the way, how big are you, seriously you're so, oh it is in the way,
I can shove it all the way in the corner,
oh I don't have the money, give me the money, we're going to shove it all the way in the corner,
okay then we need to do the thing where I need to figure out the path, oh I just clicked off the
door, it's a very buggy but a good kind of buggy, right okay bridge, click,
hold on are you doing what I think you're doing, I don't think you're okay, built,
wait what do you mean it's in the way,
fuck you,
fucking caterpillar in the way, I just spent all that money on nothing,
and it left the freaking construction behind, you stink, don't ever do that again,
well what do you think about Virginia, not just the US state asking for a reform,
speak up, you mean you're willing to give me your chair,
what happened to chat, it's peaceful, it's a little menace, okay develop bumbly beaches, small
amusement park and a thriving theme park, your objective to have at least 750 guests, oh yeah,
oh yeah Mr. Krabs and the theme park is not worth, well it's not worth millions, maybe another time,
oh we did it, post, post game yapping begins, no, still hasn't been fixed, I don't know what's
going on with the mechanic, but they're not my problem anymore, save, save, and then we're going
to do post game yapping, oh yeah Mr. Krabs, right I'll mute that and then I'll put my background
music on, but I'll still have it in the background, and then I'll go big to symbolize this post game
yapping time, that's right, we're like post game plapping time, oh you like that one, yeah you like
the other big sweat, but yes tonight I'm recording pregnant with you ASMR, well strongy you can't
do that, why not, what's stopping me, you, you're gonna stop me, less likely than you think,
no strongy you can't just post me ASMR, watch me, watch me,
grain some old school rinse cake, I am doing it at the end of this week, if you want to play,
and by play with me I mean jerk my pintus, nobody can stop, stop being strongy,
actually I need to get giantess artwork of Azura, I'm going to, I should get a comic
where everyone's like comparing our heights, so like people can learn the lore of our heights,
and then the last panels Azura being as tall as a skyscraper and all of us are like
we didn't know you could do that, but we do know she can do that, but it just helps kind of solidify
the lore of the girl, um, hi strongy, Nessie's in Loch Ness, that's why she's called Loch Ness
once though, isn't she in Loch Lomond, am I making up, am I going mental, isn't Loch Lomond
actually where, and it's like a misnomer, oh when is Azur's Donathon, Azur's Donathon is on Saturday
the 24th of August for 12 hours, it is a limited time Donathon, please do show up, I think all
of us are going to show up on our stream at one point, um, I think also a few VTubers who have
been very kind to her are also going to show up, but I'm going to help her out plan at all,
but please if you're able to show any support, even showing up, not monetary support, please
don't think you have to, monetary support, um, it's all going to be a hoot and a holler, I'm not
going to be streaming while she streams, so I'm having a short stream that day and then I'm going
to redirect into her, and then I'm going to show up in her stream most likely, so it's the Saturday
the 24th of August, her actual birthday is national goat day which is the 21st of August,
but the Saturday is the better choice, but we will start doing announcements
when it gets a bit closer to the time, and the Donathon needs to actually be solidified,
she gave me a list of what the bleeding hearts came up with, so I'm going to work with it and
then we're going to see what the response will be to the mock sheet, but at the end of her Donathon
she very most likely can move out, so I'm very excited for her to kind of level up as a content
creator, because at the moment I think it's fair to say she's a bit limited at the moment, I don't
think she would disagree with me on the assessment, she's a bit limited, but with the capabilities of
moving out, then I think Azura is going to step up her game, no that it's not stepped up, she's
doing what she can in the situation she's in, yeah, Azura is big enough to carry us all, for real,
literally you guys were like why'd you call her fondula bosom, like I already planned the giant
test boob artwork, okay, that was planned long ago, hello mommy, hi refling, I know you said you
don't try games that you might not be good at, but have you ever tried playing a fighting game,
I have never played one, but apparently you guys can stream snip and tech in or something like that,
tech in, I would 100% get absolutely walloped in a game like that with you, I wouldn't mind at all,
what, I can't stop thinking about how stinky you are and how I want to lick you clean so bad,
I'm the robin, what, no shivers for a week young lady, you have to be nice and right
for your owners, please make more sent play audios, I mean,
you feeling the sent play, you like it, okay,
whoa, wait, this is the same person, they sent three, that's my good girl, I say they slam your
survey, I can't read this, I can't read this,
I can't, the message ends with you're gonna be a good mom,
refling, refling, you're pent up, you need help, come to the convention like right now,
you need clarity, you need the mental clarity that that release will give you,
astronomy advises for us to send it and that's a challenge, you need help to send tomorrow,
question mark, oh wait, I actually have a question mark, hold on, I paid good money for this, tomorrow,
tomorrow, yeah, tomorrow, maybe, I just need to record the missing ASMRs that I couldn't record
and then tomorrow, you're doing cons, I don't know yet, I have the 12, I have the 12 anxiety
which makes things hard, I actually, I told the girls about my situation and they all said
they'd come and fly out to see me and I was like, I'm gonna cry, I love my daughters, they're too nice
to be, I explain to them like the reason why I get like severely motion sick and ill and all that
is because I have spawn, a bomb, I have to be at spawn at all times or I freak out and I can't handle
it, I can't handle it, but the girls were really nice, they were like, oh we'll come and see you,
don't forget to thank the paper, no, no, no, that was outrageous, that was an absolutely outrageous
remark, can you believe it, that was bizarre, that was like randomly attacks you, walks off
and blocks you before, you can respond, I mean I wouldn't respond, I don't respond to anything,
but it was just like, I posted it because like me and the girls like obviously we post stuff and
we're like eh, giggle, giggle and I was like damn, someone was unhappy with that, that short,
I posted emerses like I'm recognizer and I'm like oh, oh, there's a con in person, no, it would have
to be Melbourne, if we actually do a convention it would have to be Melbourne, I'm sorry, I can
hardly go anywhere, I already got so violently ill going to the airport for my dad, was she a
potential collaborator, no, not as far as I'm aware, not for me anyway, maybe they don't have
paypegs in urgent, you guys aren't paypeg, I really do not want you guys to start referring,
like I don't mind it as a meme, but seriously, oh that terminology annoys me, because it's like
that simp terminology as well, it's like can guys not fucking enjoy anything without being
like fucking criticised or like made fun of for doing it, like oh my god, oh my god, anyway,
so that's me, I don't know about you and your thoughts about the situation as a whole, but
oh my god, can guys not be allowed to enjoy one single thing without being like made fun of,
oh my god, they can't even fucking breathe, anyway, but that's just me,
okay, thought I'd send a joke to tear you up,
my beloved, oh he said the coconut from Elden Ring, what do you call a brand compromise,
what do you call a band compromise of overweight men, picnic at the disco, slim knot,
nine inch necks, rage against the vending machine, diabetals, fed zeppelin,
OB slash CD, obesity, instead obesity, instead of ACDC, nine inch neck as well,
mommy I'm at work, but the thought of you calling me a loser for letting you win in a video game
is making me a squirm and mess, I love you, I love breaking you, ravelling more and more,
tell me more about you being at work and doing things you shouldn't be, but I don't encourage it
though, for legal reasons, I do not encourage it, if HR gets involved, it wasn't me,
what are you saying, what are you saying, squibblings, my little squibbling,
imagine if I was a squid, you guys would be called squibblings, any squibblers,
I'm squibbling my squabble right now, what does sound do reeflings make, it's not oink oink,
definitely grunts and whimpers, yes, not oink oink, but yes on the whimpers,
that kind of, that's what, delicious, nutritious, not really, delicious, oh yeah,
don't call HR unstrongy, she is the HR, when one of the girls complains that I'm being too overly
bick, she will towards them, can't relate, sorry, no HR here, bye, sorry, your design's just so
I am the one who knows, wish I had strong as HR, mine screwed me over, oh I just threw up, screw you,
you can't make HR to report like harassment, me, alright, let's get to work,
me and the girls designs, I was when we do a strongy ghost house convention,
hello guys, hi, weeping, thank you for the stream, you are welcome and you do come well,
hopefully, you probably already have something prepared, but I did a quick edit of us in the
bathtub if I wanted to use it for a png, if strongy is our, I'm calling every day,
alright, okay, sorry, I was like, are you reporting me right now, please don't report
me, don't report me, I refling, oh my god, look what I just got sent, oh my god, I'm showing
it on stream right now, hold on, oh my god, stop, you're so cute, I have you, I get to have you in
the bathtub with me, scrub it up, in the bathtub, oh my god, you can be my sponge, okay refling,
time to clean, clean me, refling, good refling, good refling, keep it up, bathtub stream confirmed,
oh you're so cute, I'm ready, I'm so ready to do bathtub time with you,
bathtub time, thank you refling for sending that in, I thank you very much when you guys do edits
like that, because it's stuff that I want to do, but I get like so dragged up into work and stuff,
simply just went to the heaven, get a good taste, let it go around all 9,000 taste buds,
I turned for money, won't be difficult to keep it up,
mind me, wash your back, oh you're gonna give me back, you're gonna give me a little shoulder
massage, I kiss one tentacle, I kiss two tentacles,
I'm not going to Calamari artwork yet, we're a swole yet,
oh there's a tentacle back here but you can't see it,
please trump one tentacle, would you let me,
okay maybe not that much, you're like no thank you, I'm gone, okay I put you on my screen with me,
but you're so adorable, stop being so adorable, do you understand me,
tell them all yowch, tollmanjerry asked scream after getting bitten by these tea,
strawny please chill, please train me to enjoy loads and games, it's been stuck on my head
and it's even better knowing I'm a sore loser playing video, I love you, what you want me to
train you to enjoy it, to know what happens if you don't let me win, I mean real true,
I was wondering what's your take on artwork that's wholesome, that includes you featuring another
female chuba, and velour that you've collabed with, interacted with them, yeah of course,
it's absolutely, honestly all the fucking gloves are off with me, go for it, all the gloves are
off, you don't have to ask me permission for nothing, you don't need to ask me for permission
other than to eek, sorry I'm stretching again, hydration check dialing weakening,
it is, okay, I actually sounded like one of those screamo people, disrespect your sorrow,
dirt, ink, I don't want to know what happens if we don't let you in,
in both scenarios, you're getting r-word, I just want to say thank you, I haven't been
watching you for long, oh yeah, hi, but you are a really sweet and kind person and what you've
achieved has been amazing, I'm really happy for you, oh thank you for your extended happiness,
I'm so so kind for you to be happy for me, see that's called empathy and that's awesome to practice,
so unironically good on you for practicing empathy, if you can find happiness for others as well,
that's fantastic, I will do that in my education stream about being able to feel emotions through
other people as well, because it's important to surround yourself in an environment that you'll
thrive in, and surprise, surprise, I'm surrounded by my beautiful reeflings and I'm absolutely
thriving, I wonder if there's a correlation, it's almost like we're as addicted to each other,
um yeah, we're proud of you for sending it and gifting us wonderful veal, I remember,
I fucking love getting marshmallows and they're and it's like momay thank you so much for like
giving me mercy Azura, because you guys are like loving them and adoring them and please
enjoy them to your heart's content, don't ever feel like you're like abandoning me or anything
like that, I want you to be happy, I want you to consume people that make you happy, that's a
veal or girl or otherwise, I ain't a jealous, that's not for me, that's not my thing, I want
you happy, I want you to be able to de-stress, I want you to have some background noise that gives
you a little giggle, maybe makes you breathe air through your nose a bit faster, that's what I want,
okay, you want us to eat your daughters, now eat your mom, me shee,
strongy, how did you discover vealer, I am vealer, I'm all of you, I'm all the girls at once,
don't, I'm ac and Amy and Azura and Mercy and Sheebie, you didn't smell,
oh fuck, I was a terrible Azura, right, hold on, do ac, do ac,
that bites me, fuck, I am the Senate, I am all of vealer, do the voices, shit,
shit, hold on to the voices, um, did you miss me bleeding heart, are you excited for my
donut on the moon, I can't wait to move out so I can make all the contents in the world for you,
can you imagine it now, my little Ripley, oh, uh, bleeding heart, fuck, I'm losing it,
I'm losing it, not yet, so it's treason then, Shawnee is a big woman, dude, I'm gonna cry
ashamed here, like, I'll step in, whenever the girls are offline for the day, I'll step in and
do a little segment of pretending to be them, how about that, Azura on stream, real, she dropped
at the end, refling heart, damn, you do a fine Azura, I mean, if I whisper I can hate it enough
that it's not Azura, the vealer house is real, yeah, she's in my house right now, Azura, why are
you so tall, Jay, Azura, like, I'd be looking up like this, hi, she's so tall, yeah, hi cuddles,
I just want to let you know that I can't incomlicit your voice, oh, what the fuck,
why did that sound like I have a kazoo on the end of my throat, what was that, did you hear that,
that sounded like a broken door or something on its hinges, that was my voice, I'm gonna take a
hydration check, what the heck, hydration, hydration, you turned into the chicken toy again, no,
oh, I've forgotten how I did it though, they're doing, would love an Australian Emmy,
how would I do that, what's wrong, big brother, it doesn't sound like that,
what are you done, you're out, she's not that high pitched, but for some reason, I think in my head
my voice is deeper than what it is, so when I try and mimic someone, I go overboard trying to mimic,
if the vealer house was real, they would need a HR department and they would be begging me to shut
up, because I like scurreme, I mean, you guys hear, I scurreme, my dad actually complained on the
Mario Kart stream, I woke him up while I was playing Mario Kart and I was being like, you're
supposed to let me win, he was like, you're so, I'm like, I'm sorry, I don't fucking have any idea
what the neighbor's like, what S stream, honestly, HR stands for huge arse department, I like that
one, I like that one, I like that one, I like that one, I've keeping that one, that one's mine,
thank you, getting reported to the huge arse department ASMR win, and it's just me sitting on
the mic, well, I've actually already made that, changing the title right now,
I just want to let you know, you haven't done much hypno content yet, and I'm already
pinches broken, please break me more and mold my brain, my pinches and behind, into your tie,
oh it's fucking over for you if you're already, but I like it that way,
I can't wait to hear the jingle of the caller while you bounce on it,
I can't read that, I can't read it, do you understand me, hi Stroni, hi reading,
this is about the other question about commissioning artwork, oh yeah, I meant wholesome art featuring
you in a female literature that's not in the alert, yeah, yeah, I mean if we interacted with them,
then that means I'm cool with them, and they're cool with me, because if they aren't cool with me,
you publicly wouldn't know I've interacted with them, are you squinting me right now,
did your dad hear you yelling about how you were gonna, our word the reeflings for beating you,
and how you were gonna run a train on them after breaking into our houses,
technically yes, I woke him up
and he was awake and like watching youtube videos waiting for me to finish my streams,
so the answer is yes, he heard the ring fit as well, and I was like okay, rather cringe,
thank you tiny spiny for the hit, but yeah, yo, I wasn't here for the Mario Kart stream, what happened,
when I get angry, I sometimes make threats against the reeflings, and I'm a bad person for it,
and I should be ashamed, but I can't stop, because I get really angry and they're just so cute and
adorable, and they need to let me win, and I start screaming in it anyway,
I can't read any of these, someone is, someone needs to release right now, because you're doing it,
and marshmallows, I can't read them out, hey story, listening to you at a restaurant with a
fam, truly a hard challenge, just struggling not to squirt with your voice, also clam slam me please,
you want clam slam and elton ring blessings again, okay, you get clam slam at restaurant,
I got red lobster, are you squidding me right now, red lobster, did you just make brian
beatbox, did you just make brian beatbox, wrap to it, are we supposed to wrap to that, oh my god,
right, okay, we'll try again, we'll try again, hold on, are you squidding me right now, we're to
wrap to this, I'm a reefling, streamer like this, this is so distracting, this is crazy,
thank you eyeperror, brian, why is he saying beach mouse, is that supposed to be
mud on your face, your big disgrace, something else my arse on your face, we will, we will
face it, okay, I had a dream where we were kissing and I was so pent up, I woke up and
I woke up you, tasted and felt so good, I love you, I love you reefling, are you dreaming of me,
do I look like, how do I look like here in your dream, I don't, my dreams never work out to
anything, all my dreams are nightmares from high school, all my dreams are like nightmares, I have
a lot of kittens getting heart dreams as well, I had a cat dream, oh my god, I had a freaking cat
dream last night, I had a kitten, no I had a cat that I adopted and it had kittens before I could
get it neutered and I was so worried about it because obviously it's very dangerous for cats to have
well it's dangerous for anything to give birth because you know giving birth is dangerous
and I felt so bad and rotten because I put her in so much pain, yeah, so this is, I have nightmares
about like cats getting hurt and stuff, I don't like it, I love my poodles, I love all poodles,
I've never been so jealous of a cat dream, no I hate the dreams, yeah,
stronti, stronti is a true goth only nightmares, I never remember good dreams, they say you dream
every night but I only seem to ever remember the negative stuff which is always like cats getting
hurt and stuff and I hate it, like I'll wake up and I'll know it's not real but I hate it, I hate it,
I just got here, why do I look so cute as a reef on a screen, that's you in the bathtub
getting ready to sponge me down for the 10k is more screen, I don't really have dreams,
someone pointed out it's a sign of psychopathy, what, psychopathy, I'm sure you're right,
I rarely dream but when I do it it's getting rather weird, I only remember nightmares and
dirty dreams, I think I'm too stressed to have dirty dreams, you're my dream, literally you're
my dream, I wake up, wake up, it's the first of the month, no, but like we send each other,
well I say we send each other, I'm gonna start using my alt twitter more, okay, I promise you just
need to let me cook because I'm a bit behind, I didn't actually expect to be so behind on work
when my dad visited but, ah, hi strongy, how we playing, alt time, I saw Mercy posted this thing
on her alt and I'm like I'm so ready to absolutely annihilate everyone by writing stuff like that,
like doing like small creative things like that, I cannot wait to do it and it's over for your
pentas, hi strongy, hi meeting, thank you for making Hypno themed ASMR this week, I hope you're
looking forward to it, I have to script it and I'm not looking forward to scripting it because I
get worried I'm going to mess up and then someone's going to be like eh you're not really in a hypno
you're just doing it for the gag and it's like no I like it, I'm going to the UK, any recommendations
for what to do in Scotland as much as it pains me, I was like last week and Edinburgh has better
tourist attractions, there's the National Museum in Edinburgh and then there's also an art gallery,
it will probably take like three hours to do them both, like together, if you kind of want to
blitz through it, the National Museum is a lot better than the art gallery, if you're not really
into art but I like physical art, like the old physical art, does that make sense, what's the
most down bad thing you've ever done, before debut someone wrote a green text post, I said I'm a way
to work, I shlicked and I posted the evidence on my alt twitter, I literally like, I think it was
it wasn't even major, it was like eight sentences and obviously because of the stress of like
organising violour, I had not done anything for ages and someone made this like a really quick
post and I read it and I was like well that's enough for me to get started, that's probably the
most down bad because it was like eight sentences and it was just pixels on a screen you know,
like it was just words on a screen, it wasn't like it was a video or an audio or anything of that
nature, it was just words on a screen and it was like eight sentences, yeah I was pretty down bad,
not gonna lie that was like really down bad, dudes would see two circles and go hmm I'm only human
after all, I'm only a cuttlefish after all, imagination is so so much more powerful, real
true based, retweet, repost anything, true true true, I'd make you have sweet nasty dreams,
if I was using my mouth on you will you sleep, no no mouth on clam, like two, don't say that to me,
no mouth on clam and I'm the one who does stuff to you in your sleep, not the other way around,
I want to spend a week inside of you, soft or hard, sleeping, working, playing video games,
eating, going to the bathroom, picking up flirries, you want to be in my tummy or do you want to be
in my womb, well if you be in my womb I can keep you in for longer, if you're in my tummy you may
get digested, I'm not gonna lie, we need to think of the logistics of this, oh thank you
Rilke Cadmus, I appreciate that, I'm just worried like because I've never had a big massive wallop
at it like I've enjoyed it in passing and all of that but like to actually make it it makes me so
nervous, oh that's something I have insecurity about, the quality of my hypno content, oh there's
my weakness, there you go, we were kind of talking about how like I don't have imposter syndrome or
anything like I'm not gonna get out with that but I don't normally have weaknesses when it comes to
content creation because you're gonna get what you get, I'm never going to be a 10 out of 10
but hypno content I'm actually a bit insecure about so there you go there's a little insecurity
that you can poke and prod me with if you really want, how much rent you asking for the worm,
oh for the whim, no rent for free, whim, a whole week no pillow, real, only wiefling arm, I do it
to you but you can't do it to me, you get a dorm loss, dorm loss is fine, I'm fine with dorm loss
that doesn't bother me at all, if anything I encourage dorm loss, yes yes yes yes yes
and it's your lore unfortunate by like hypno stuff, yeah I I wanted to try it that's what it's all
that's what strongy's all about, see I promise I'll I paid a lot of money for these I promise
I'll use the toggles okay I promise I'm gonna use them on the hypno stream okay so you know
and then if you need something a bit bigger to focus on then I can leave this in the background
whilst the spiral still goes you know okay okay back to back to being a cut of the stone
but it'll be fine, just send that hypno as much as it can
I'm only okay I will send it but I need to make the script that's the only thing
okay you're allowed to my whim for a week okay there's no rent
but you do need to hit the magic switch and say it because if you didn't know there's a g-spot inside
and you would be right at it
from the stream yesterday Azur's hair is green like Hudson Miku which is also why
Miku has a leak wait did they no they didn't they didn't cut nah they did not color code the items
they gave vocaloids because I know for a fact yawain or whatever yawa the drunk alcoholic ones
are tuna fishes you know and then a bread is teto from vocaloid I can't remember what
Len and Rin is but Nero what's Nero's food item I don't know I think Nero's her mobile phone
you're trolling me tetu is an Utau tuna sandwich one of them one of them's a tuna
yeah she has a leak because she has a leak Miku is
I mean how is Miku or a green sorry I'm getting I'm getting I'm fighting the color schemes
Emmy's ginger okay full stop um Hudson Miku are you not blue am I going crazy that's blue
surely I'm not blue green colorblind that I've typed in Hudson Miku is a sea of blue I wouldn't
argue any of these are green swim suit fan art wallpaper real true I can't help it
pop it's been so long since we've had to let loose it's all we can think about we need to
hear you lose your mind love you be playing love you too but you can't tease me tomorrow
wait until tomorrow you can tease me all you want you've programmed me so much it's literally difficult
to do a solo session without listening to I don't think it's sense I'll send it again just in case
I love how easy and effortless it would be for me to overpower and dumb you but I pretend to be
weak and afraid and that I have no choice to let you have your way with me what do you mean
I'm so strong my wrists don't crack at all when I open water balls your accusations are unfounded
refling and me is blonde will you outward me for my insolence towards absolutely
are we the hypno Miku's hair is a blue green it's blue it's not a blue green my hair is green
look at the tips of my hair look at my tip yeah that's right look at my tip refling yeah you like
that have you seen her ring fit gameplay a true monster of strength the ring fit no so the problem
is all my strength is in my thighs and my buttocks and my legs I have no upper body strength at all
my wrists my arms my hands I have nothing to offer I literally couldn't hold the ring fit
thing above my head in that parachute game because I had to stretch the like device open
it was not possible skipped arm day literally I have nothing in my upper body
like if I'm having to beat you up you're literally getting kangaroo kicked I'm not even kidding
like I will jump up mid-air and then ping you back with both legs
Stony's hair is what I'm in
so yeah arm day she skipped arm year basically yeah like my wrist cracking all that and just
leg lock me yeah I can do that that's easy try and try oh I should offer that at the convention
five dollars try and get out of my leg lock and if you win you get your you get double the money
back I'm like double or double or nothing here's an idea what if you have a stream where you tell
the reeflings you control when they ink but in the stream you tell them they have to save it and have
them do it next stream like if I did back-to-back bansley streams
hmm that's evil evil like a siren I'm a siren maybe just maybe
yeah that is evil and now you put that thought in my head
would anyone even want to try and get out of the head lock directions unclear inked everywhere
five dollars for an egg lock an egg lock no a leg lock I'm asleep in that a siren and along
getting my 10 quid ready the new she's too powerful it's okay no peril diving only tongue
punching your spelunk box that's an actual sentence oh I need a copy and paste that and put it in chat
oh wait why is it a link oh look at that
and that's an actual sentence that I was saying
it's such a good sentence it's such a good sentence that's such a good sentence I'm not even mad
love you love you too reefling thank you for giving me a giggle that's such a good sentence honestly
um oh shit okay I think Gimli is trying to break in I want to train you to
crave the smell of my tentacle wait who's getting
who's getting who's the dome because it doesn't even look like me
me
if you know where all his reeflings live and decide to break into one of our homes to
Incas do not stop please I will let you become your personal reefling cow oh my god right I
think I'm doing a bit too much I think I've got you all in a choke hold at the moment
sorry you guys are choking and holding if you know what I'm saying
you are not a dumb for sure ah
the accusations that are against me the aliguncy
I'm only human after all
um
kiss I feel like the deep from the boys would be your biggest fan stop didn't he hump our octopus
why hump an octopus when you can hump a cuttlefish
strony only acts dumb so she can get dumb lost I'm sorry if you don't see it but
Stoney is 100% a don who dabbles in the law he did more than hump it
I love that word hump I'm humping you
Ace more but I just say hump a thousand times
no mouth on clam how about tongue on starfish followed by a girthy tentacle the way we are
getting around this is hilarious I am loving all the euphemisms like coming together because
I'm aquatic themed I love it reeflings you're so creative please don't stop I love it please it's
so good it's so good ASMR microphone back shot oh you want to go in the ASMR booth right now
huh
oh that's amazing most useful right okay okay no more
will you ever do a siren themed audio uh yes hypnosis absolutely um singing themed not really
I'm singing to you in my pregnancy ASMR I'm actually singing
I'm out of breath but you know I'm singing I'm gonna sing that to you in the the roleplay
but actual singing ASMR like
she's French no I'm Scottish but Scotland and France are close together so I had mandatory
French lessons in school so if you want to say je parlez le franais that made French people
grimace because that's incorrect French lingo coconut cracking ASMR I was gonna do watermelon
thingy what's all this talk about clams and eels and chocolate starfish is
how we get around how we get around save your pure so a clam is my and then a tentacle is your
and then a chocolate starfish is this part
um
how we behave because we always behave don't we be flings we're good boys or
well I'm a good girl but you're a good boy aren't you you're my good boy keep up
I have never acted out once you cannot prove it
uh no singing but just the regular thingy um
is it weird hearing her pent up some of these annons are making me pent up as well
oh great I need to help us all calm down okay because we're going overboard
we're going overboard right let me see if I can redirect into someone okay the only reason I'm
going off early don't say no it's because mommy doesn't love me mommy loves you very much mommy
frickin had to put so much work aside that it's all piled up on my desk and it is
overwhelming um it's overwhelming
it's overwhelming hold on
so I'm having to do a lot of catch-up I'm gonna upload mine in Azur's I might go for an app first
so just relax but I do need to do her thing okay I'm wondering how reeflings can train
you as a submissive the way you dominate us uh you have to find me on a good day it's very hard
to get me into subspace because I find it difficult to get into I'd rather dominate the
ever-loving daylight out of you guys Imi is in half an hour oh she's in half an hour is Imi early
I'm looking I'm analizing I'm analizing Imi Bezu oh god what who named her honestly fantastic
name uh-huh legal stick stop wait poppy's playtime AAM all right okay you're gonna listen to your
little sister fucking scream but not for those reasons actually because she's playing horror
game smile not for those reasons she's playing a horror game she's playing poppy's playtime
chapter three which I actually haven't seen so I hope she enjoys it because I don't know what it's
about I do not know so if I don't know what it's about then how dare how dare and
uh we're gonna listen to our little sister what one time for you let them know code strongy
for gamer stops for 10% off if you support me or any of the girls then we may or may not be getting
a cup which would actually be pretty cool um yeah um and then yeah bye merch or else yes please don't
be afraid the girls get a hundred percent of the cut from uo market they get a hundred percent of
the cut from gamer subs we uh veal or I say we veal or we do not take any of it I want the girls
to succeed as much as possible um again when it comes to bansley 100% like we'll be transparent
the base cut is 80 20 I mean heck even the yumi plus watch alongs they got 100% um because I was
like oh that's your first time being sponsored here's the money I don't really want to you know I don't
really I don't I don't really like greed I don't know it's kind of I don't know if you kind of picked
up on that a little bit of um a little bit of my mantra but yeah I kind of can't stand greed makes
my skin crawl so didn't he be surprised if you see there is big projects coming up what what what
what did you just say strongy wait I guess oh strongy you normally tell us everything are you
hiding something strongy I don't know maybe I may I may for once in my life I may have to shut
off about a surprise that's coming in the future the future when what's the timeline I don't know
what what would be the timeline I do not know is it related to your doughnut on no no it's not
actually uh you might know about this super awesome secret before my doughnut on maybe possibly who
knows 10th of june 10th of october june was last month um october um so before the 10th of october
something's happening oh no no no no I cannot prove it maybe after october you never know
and emmy's almost 17k I'm humping the stream to support my daughter oh before you go right we're
all gonna open up the same youtube video okay and then we're all gonna play it at the same time so we
can all listen to it at the same time do you understand say yes mommy we're all gonna open up
this clip and we're all gonna react to it at the same time okay oh that was my nope that's my daughter
hold on right okay everyone open up this link but don't don't play it yet don't play it yet wait is
that the wrong link be honest did I just link to the one thing did I just link to oh no that's the
right thing okay I'll give you a second open up that link pause it at zero zero zero okay I'll tell
you when to play it and I'm gonna mute my desktop because oh no my desktop is muted so you couldn't
hear in the first place okay are you ready are you steady so I'm gonna say three two one go
and on go we do it okay ready three two one go
showed what emmy
look at you pin pals egging her on big brother what are you doing to my little this my little door
instructions unclear I inked
oh I love the wee bubble sound when she pinches the sweater
actually I think she's got bigger mountains than I do
hold on we're gonna analyze frame by frame I think emmy actually has a bigger chest than me
I think I might actually have the smallest chest out of everyone in view
I think I might have the smallest chest out of everyone like 99% sure I do
fucking hell 400 just like that
I love her laugh
oh my god you could hear the unzip
oh my god the fart notification is hilarious
okay we're about to confirm if I've got to pretend to be a woman
literally she didn't require the zip.mp3
let's see it come on show us the goods little sis
oh yeah she definitely has
oh my gosh she has way bigger than me my POV is like
am I
like you got another 50 holy crap
extraordinary mercy is definitely small
oh yeah no she 100% go bigger than me okay okay I did I think I was just confirmed I've got the smallest
oh my god what we tend to this is my favorite thing about letting the girls do whatever they want
is I get to come online the next day and be like what but like what is in a good way not as in a
what is in oh my god doesn't read you shouldn't be doing that um no chat's are real I'm back I
bet you all missed my talented what honestly that I fucking love it I love just like like
coming on and be like what you guys up to what's going on here uh oh my god someone commented
two minutes ago she's bigger than her model it's so over what strony got a whole baker
yes I got a baker remember strony size doesn't matter not for booba I actually don't mind having
small in my honkers I don't mind having mini milk at all and whenever like I spoke to the girls
like when we were sharing earth I couldn't miss each other um ever they kept like she'd be in that
we're all like oh my god I wish I had um knee milkers because my back is all sore in that and I'm
like oh I believe you because they're so serious about it you're sharing what then I'll tell you
how we did our little family bonding time we were sending photos of each other I was literally in
gen chat as well it's not even like it was in like private dms or anything we're just like yep this is
me I like yep this is me um the forbidden discard honestly honestly um
someone says as I said before never underestimate the human determination I'm gonna give that a
thumbs up on that comment I'm gonna you're getting a thumbs up from me at a good comment
fellas you did this too we are through
strongy the discord messages were leaked no that meme please recreate that meme
please recreate that meme for me please put the little cut fish hair on the president and
poke in be like strongy the discord dms were leaked it's so over
are you squidding me right now can someone fork over 400 bucks hi strongy thanks for helping to
make valour I've had more fun watching you and the other girls than I have watching other streamers
in a long time thank you for being open to us link three two two to be very specific with the
numbers at the end of your name thank you for being open to us a lot of people now so familiarity
is um a very um potent to drug of no drug if you will and thank you for being open to us
because like obviously we got a lot of flak on first booted up like folk were like oh my god the
infighting's gonna go wild mean where we're like literally in each other's dms like here's a picture
of my ass um and they're like oh there's infighting and all that the company's gonna implode or
whatever and it's like obviously because your first interaction could visibly visibly a velour
could have been like a negative opinion you can maintain that negative opinion without ever having
consumed any of us genuinely that's like a thing that happens like um I've kind of seen it on
amaranth if you didn't know amaranth gets like a hell a lot of flak and people will go watch her
for the first time and be like oh she actually like isn't that bad at all type thing and then
it's kind of like a repeating pattern it happens like public's opinion that i've never consumed that
creator can overshadow the actual creator and what they do and it isn't until you go out of your
comfort zone and consume a new content creator that you can kind of like challenge those like
impressions or um those thoughts that or things that you might have thought were true but then
like you're hopping stream and it's like oh shit let's play sonic heroes um and uh even
i've only had two hours of sleep type thing you know i'm not new at v2 is that the community is
the best place i've been and lots of love to go around here and i'm super stoked for what's to
come are you excited for the super secret thing that i can't talk about yet yeah yeah yeah i'm no
fan of hers but i do recognize she's a business partner appreciates how she's a profit to look
after animals oh right okay i was like me i was like gambling my cat i'm beagle i just feel
we're growing in five more years or something like that five five more years five more years
five more years what's the super secret no i'm not telling you i for once i have a secret
that i cannot spoil because it will spoil it for my daughters so i can't spoil it
i do not know but veiler video game leaks do you want more we're almost done we're at the last
stages of animation and then i need to hand over all the audio files i need to record all
so much i need to record so much but we're doing it anonymous who goes there identify yourself hi
stroney hi anonymous i've gotten to see a lot of vtubers in my algorithm since subscribing to you
they're all fun to react to but i think i enjoy growing with a new channel like veiler oh that's
so nice yeah some people say it's harder to get into a channel that's already like established but
i hope i feel welcoming to anyone i do understand like i incident go like reeflings and you might
not know that your name is reefling i'm legally changing your name to reefling on paper um are
you squiddin me right now animations and audio i really wish i started watching veiler sooner
when i first saw tweets about the group's debut i thought are great more loot tubers and i had a
negative view of you guys but just a few days ago i found that you guys are genuinely really
entertaining oh thank you yes that was actually thank you for being honest about that as well
basically was thank you for the tip that was a lot of feedback was like oh great more loot tubers but
it's like you kind of have to understand that a lot of people thought we were like going to be
humping the screen on youtube and it's like uh no this is youtube we're here to play video
and just offer the fun stuff on the side like gee i mean it's for free as well if you go in the
alt tours i mean yet aim emi has a whole freaking menu for you to scroll through when you go in her
alt tour get in she's so organized i'm like bro funny copy and paste emi is organized to only
humping 50 percent we're not just popcorn um just a little screen okay i was on board day one
aw but yeah hopefully like it still feels welcoming even if you might have come in a bit later
like i don't i mean i don't think any really she's gonna be sexy wholesome and funny
hi jayson check i just didn't really watch me tubers before because of the amongos you had
with yumi plus i've been checking them out when i can yes always rip for the underdog soon i will
not be the underdog and eat my words but um i think it's nice to give like smaller indy or
smaller agencies a chance to kind of shame are you squiddin me right now mom alone i hope i am
welcoming two minutes after a refling subscribes i will score pure tentacle look i've been taking
out a context okay that didn't happen you can't prove it thank you mom alone for this super chat
you can't prove it but there is no context i'm gonna start acting up in front of marine wildlife
because yeah no no no no no no no that's funniest look i never watched a vtuber because
they were a vtuber to be honest i think i would still love all you girls if you weren't vtuber
well i'm okay well okay okay i was gonna say something about self-depressed i love to
get in but i'm not allowed to say it because you guys have taught me not to and i must be nice to
myself one hello mommy hi bifling i've noticed that the veiler models are super expressive good
i spent money on it i see a lot more married math movements and expansions that i don't know
i don't know if you're on a reach or if i'm really cool yeah you're like that i'm like
i've still not even gnarly cooked so hard on these models i've still not even like i actually
sink this to anything and it it just works cod howard gnarly it just works but yes this is us
gnarly cooked so hard literally worth every penny sorry i cannot craze gnarly enough
all right gremlin energy like you can see my
anyway so that's me showing off the rigging i'm actually gonna be making gnarly a showcase soon
because she doesn't know how to do it and i was like let me allow me gnarly i will cook what you wish
you wish please those cc cucumbers that they're clearing up my act and i hold on a minute we're
shoving aquatic animals up our hearts unless it's me that i'm sorry i'm sorry i'll stop talking
how much do we pay piggy no no don't you fucking star how much is it to pay for 3d
allow me to worry about that i'm having a discussion with the girls soon about what
the plan is the 3d what i need to know from the girls is are we paying for your tracking
if they pay for it out of their 80 percent then obviously the 3d can come a lot faster
um anonymous how do you not have so much fun making faces where you're avatar when you're
on stream well i mean i should use my my my toggles more but i'm thinking i never dare
are you forgive me for being stinky you like my sense don't you
you like how unbelievably stinky i am when i pheromone that right
what's that one oh it's sweat i want to make you sweat
i should do more but i don't i'm stinky okay i don't i'm just taking up the whole stream now
wow we are mummy sense and pavement no that's literally the drill why hey let guys enjoy
what they want to enjoy oh my god imagine our reefling 3d modelers donating you a new suit
do you need a suit to do 3d i might ask the girls if they have 3d experience if they don't
then we're all we're all on a journey together because i don't know a thing about it although
i'm probably gonna harass and sister about it because she has a 3d she stinks but she stinks so good
ah you smell so good reefling
wait hold on a minute do you have ink inside you right now
okay it's in contain that smelly smell it depends on what kind of tracking some things are suits
i sound like the suit would be better
always have
strony pheromone cologne when i know she's on to um are you squiddin me right now we could be your
i recall that you said that you watch your vod's yeah so i have a question how did you feel after
watching the supermarket simulator vod where we praised you like the good little puppy i don't
watch the full tang i like do the tame stamp and then i skip to the bits that i remember um thank
you anonymous for the tip tease me tomorrow um i try to tame stamp i don't always do it but like
i'll do it for games that are like super yappy uh where would you ask me oh um when i stream i
actually don't remember like anything i say does that make sense like i don't remember anything
that has occurred until i rewatch the vod i think because i'm like so focused on like
like trying to read and then play a game oh my god i know reading takes a lot of mental
focus i know i'm aware i'm aware um thank you for saying it out loud strony we already know
i know i know um thank you thank you i'll be here all week uh but yeah like i don't actually
remember what occurs in stream until afterwards which is why i can rewatch myself um i really
can't always remember but i want strony sit on my face wait you're the freaking panty stealer
hold on a minute hold on a minute good is that the door
okay there i did get out you're welcome mommy when will you post the pictures from the puzzle
stream oh right i'll get the girls to tweet them out there's the kind of like goofy stuff
strony before you go can you pant for a good pot what can't wait before you go can you
pant for me like a good puppy before you go
naughty that's naughty
she she she but yeah uh riefling group self love when you want to group
bastard stream you want to you want to what you want to group
in five minutes right five minutes right now let's go
why
i wasn't able to clip from vods for the last couple of days before because of insomnia
unleashed oh no don't ever feel forced to clip it's unhealthy you need to look after your health
are they still worth something no they're always worth something so what happens is i will sit down
every week on a day and i go through what um is clipped with me in that week and things that are
suitable to be turned into a short get turned into a short arissa is working very hard right
now she's getting a few more highlight stream highlight stuff going on um um me and the homies
goodbye from real group good girl pet play allegation all of us have failed the pet play
allegations after that i want to thank you because you've broken me from my addiction now i'm just
addicted to you and i'd have it no other way okay okay that's good i thought it was a thing i love
you more than ah i love you too little weeping you made my life so much brighter i'm yours forever
i love you all re-lens stop being so nice to me i'm glad that you have been able to handle
your popcorn addiction a bit better i'm not sure i'm the best solution but i might be slightly
better and then like straight up i'm not sure i'm the best solution in that matter but um i'm
glad your popcorn addiction has reduced poggers you're doing great keep it up call me amori eel
the way i'd live inside of your reef that is so good why are you so creative that's crazy
have my lovely lady lunch check it out stroneys trainer you're always such a good girl stroney
keep it up and i'll give you a nice treat no set good go stop stop chat is this really
you girls have made my weeks really fun and i'm actually watching most of the streams i can
follow which is something i couldn't in the past where there's the only thing about me i'm really
unfriendly if you want to watch every single stream it's not possible i it's not humanly possible
hi stroney hi reeflings i'm wondering how reeflings can train you as a submissive no no you're not
hook two trade offer you receive my incontenical i receive the loss of my v card the best time
in my life in a dream come true you're offering me your boy cherry am i allowed please please let me
take it i'll give you the wildest five minutes of your life before my thighs give out
the wildest five minutes but you'll only need two minutes to ink i'll hypnotize you too whilst i
do it give me your boy cherry give me your boy cherry give me your boy cherry what if you tied
a reefling up and would uh face whenever you stream was that sentence re typing that one handed
fun language fact not all languages have word for every color blue and green in a particular
language may only have sums and others okay so everyone's colorblind got it
we can tease you tomorrow what happens tomorrow i'm gonna use my alt swear oh yeah
we gladly offer you the boy cherry sounds like an absolute win but only to the best girl
i can ink any time as long as you want three seconds take it or leave it i'll take it i think
premature is really cute i like it but i'm not sure everyone likes it i don't know i'll see what
the response to the audio is that goes please don't read on stream
okay
okay i read it now what okay i read it i did it i did it it was just his home address
i'm literally going to all your houses tonight forget Santa strong he's strong he's coming to
your house strong he's coming to your house
okay right no more yapping because guess what your little sister's getting spiked
oh wait well i stall for three minutes until she's actually online real true
base right i'm gonna redirect into me so don't worry if you're wanting to see me
i'm just gonna see if she's coming up everything's coming up any oh she's up
right okay she's up she's online right my little reeflings i have had a fun a blast a come
i'm sorry stop stop stop this madness i've had so much fun playing this old-ass janky
game well it's not actually a janky game at all it's a 10 out of 10 that is insane a guy coded this
in his room with a box of scraps and you and then someone doesn't want to give this game a 10 out of
10 don't believe it okay uh again the endurance streams start up near the end of the week and
then next week oh boy you're gonna love the roster for next week i've got some creative things going
on for you okay i see you goofy gobas very shortly and tomorrow we are playing
i can hear seagulls outside my room we where i'm opening up the my community post so i can read
bit little kitty big city okay gonna be honest the odds of me playing diva pinata tomorrow are
incredibly high i'm not sure i want to do little kitty big city if i get all my work done we'll swap
deal i'll try my best to do the work i need to do that immediately immediately needs my attention
the odds of diva pinata are very high tomorrow okay that's all i'm saying i need to get all my work
done okay um right thank you so so much time to pucker up um do you like when i do the little
squeak when i kiss you like that oh i love that i do like with it
okay now go kiss your sister no
fiery flings i see tomorrow
kiss your sister